i know that you're starving for
something you can't touch but you'll be
honest with me right now
there's something in the undercurrent i
can feel it coming up don't you want to
feel it
don't you wanna feel it
don't you wanna don't you wanna
tell me that you wanna stay baby just
don't walk away i need you now
faded out
all the time we spent alone fighting
through the fires don't don't let me
down
i need you now cause i'm feeling worn
out it's getting to me
lost some heart trying to get on my feet
caught in the madness i feel you somehow
don't let me go
i need you right now i wanna be next to
you
you wanna be next to me
holding our paper hearts fading out
broken dreams i wanna be
next to me
broken dreams
uh
tell me that you wanna stay baby just
don't walk away
don't let me down
i need you now cause i'm feeling
don't let me go i need you right now
i wanna be next to you you wanna be next
to
you me be next to me
you wanna be next to me
held your hand
i don't have a clue
because i'm
missing you
because i miss blue
i was chasing all the wrong sides
trying to hold on to something that i
couldn't find
now
don't
because i'm missing
because i'm missing you
because i'm missing you
is
okay
i was running
to the
on a saturday night i was doing
just out on my own
for me
hello everyone have you ever made a
forum like this or maybe made an api
request and then had an error like this
turn up in your application later on
down the track
yeah i have and i've seen it plenty of
time and it's a pain in the ass
and you'll eventually end up like this
guy just like annoying of these errors
like ah just
stop
well
there is a better way and
by the end of this talk i'll promise my
promise to you is that you'll know a
little bit more about functional
programming and in the library fpts
and then where to go from here and where
to learn more about it if you're
interested
so first let's look at an example
this is a simple function which just
goes to an api and downloads some data
and returns it
as a result
um and i want you to look for a few uh
errors or air places where this function
can fail
i'll wait
i mean it's a simple function right all
it does is it just saves some data and
returns it well i see two areas for
problems to arise firstly this
i just blindly assign the result to a
type assuming it's of a certain type uh
i've seen this fail countless times
um even when the api we can trust the
api or whether it's our api stuff goes
wrong somewhere so this this is bound to
cause errors and then also secondly i
have a bit of a problem with uh this
return type promise
this is more of a
technical one but
this function returns an error right and
this promise doesn't really tell us
whether or not this function returns an
error so as a consumer of this function
you either have to you know look into it
and check
and then go that way or just program
defensively
and so that means you have to assume
that every promise can fail and by
extension you like why do you stop at
promises you have to assume that every
function can fail and so are you just
going to wrap
try catches around every single uh
every single function that happens
um what if you look in this function you
see it doesn't fail
so you don't handle it and then down the
track it gets changed um
by by yourself or someone else or even
it's a dependency you have no idea that
this function change and it can now
throw an error and then boom your
application blows up to me this seems
like a sub a sub optimal solution and i
think we can do better
so
let's look a bit into
uh before we look into the solution
let's look a bit into functional
programming and fpts and their pros and
cons
so
the way i like to explain functional
programming to someone who already has
typescript knowledge
is
it kind of does the same
for typescript as what typescript does
to javascript so
if you go from javascript to typescript
you kind of get data contracts
so
this means that touchscreen says hey you
know i'm going to handle making sure
that all the data flows around your
application correctly and that you know
all these all these return types and
parameter types and everything you set
up they all match together perfectly i'm
going to handle that for you and so you
can lean on the
the the compiler to to help you ensure
that your data flows around correctly
and then if something breaks it will
tell you if you're a factor or something
i see
functional programming working the same
way
except with behavior
so now no longer are you just encoding
your how the data flows around your
application but you're also encoding how
the errors and the success states and
how your app how your functions and
applications actually behave you're
encoding that into the type system and
you can start to lean on the compiler to
help you ensure that your
your function
your application kind of fits together
these these behaviors fit together so if
a function can throw an error you're
forced to handle it you have to handle
it and also lets you know if something
changes or things like this in the
future so it can be very very useful
uh and set up with the right kind of
framework it's not super cumbersome as
we'll see
and
another thing i like to say about
functional programming is let's let's
you know
often you'll be writing
non-functional code so object oriented
or something like this
and you kind of will be adopting best
practices uh having guidelines
and you try to get your code to a good
state and sometimes it can feel like
you're pushing
a ball up a hill
so then when you actually get to
the top of the hill
it can feel like your your your code can
kind of fall out of this happy state
super easy
if someone just doesn't follow the
code guidelines or the you know some
code review is missed like this ball can
very easily roll off the top and you're
back in a bad state where your code
isn't correct or test testable or
isolatable
etc
functional programming is often seen as
a pit of success
um because of how
it
forces you to architect your
applications
since it forces you to write your
applications in a certain way and then
it has the compiler to help you out
it's
seen as a lot easier to
uh
get your
um your code into this pit of success
where it's kind of harder to push to put
to get out of it
if you if you step outside the compiler
says hey look that's not going to work
buddy
um
and
and it pushes you back into there
there's you know there's no there's less
room for error that's why it's called a
pit of success
and i believe there's actually three
pits of success with um
functional code
uh
isolation correctness and testability
this talk will focus mostly on
correctness
but if you're looking for an explanation
about other um
other
or even looking for an explanation about
how
uh function functional programming leads
to the other pits of success check out
this talk from mark seaman uh honestly
it's really really good it's now long
and his other talks are also amazing
honestly let's go just go check it out
it's great
so on to fpts this is a library for
typescript which implements functional
programming
it's written by a guy called giulio
kenti uh it's been around for a while
it's got 4.7 k stars so it's pretty
um pretty stable and it has a an
ecosystem of libraries which we will see
later on
some pros and cons in my eyes
i think that
functional code is more correct
because of the
the types and the and the behaviors and
how it's encoded there's less code based
just by design
refactoring becomes easier because you
can lean on the compiler to ensure your
behavior and errors are handled
correctly validation becomes easier as
you'll see in this talk
code becomes more isolated and thus
becomes more testable
on the downsides unfortunately
typescript wasn't made for fp so the
experience won't be quite as elegant as
it is in
languages like haskell or fsharp which
are designed for
functional programming but don't let
this sway you i think it's still uh
there are still benefits to be had but
maybe if you're you know if you're sold
in this function think you'll you'll
switch to one of those languages in the
future but it's i think it's nice to be
able to to try it out in typescript
anyway without having to change
everything
um
and also in the same way that typescript
isn't really recommended for super small
projects this also isn't really
recommended for super small projects um
it's recommended for big projects
because it helps you maintain projects
over time
and lastly uh my another downside is
your qa team might not have any work to
do so
your manager might come to you and say
hey man like give me some bugs so the qa
team can like check them and you're like
sorry dude got nothing
imagine that not running any bugs
well functional programming won't stop
you writing all your bugs but they'll
definitely help you stop writing some
so
let's look and look a little bit into
how functional application is
architected
usually we have this kind of pure area
where everything is nice and perfect and
we have this impure layer which is the
interface the outside world
where your validation your side effects
and so on happen and you have this
little guard that stands there
and let's look at what's a simple
example of how we can kind of fix our
problems from before
so
you probably already have this type for
your
api response
and how we would do this with fpts and
its system library iots if we would
rewrite that type using iots iots is
like a
type system
excuse me
ots is a type system
and we can just straight modify that
across
iots is really powerful it has lots of
custom types you can define your own
types honestly it's great
and then
we can also pull that touchscript type
out at the bottom you see type i use it
so we're pulling that pulling out an
actual state the same type out of it uh
in the end
but what this allows us to do is that if
we look at our function from before
rewritten
we have this user.decode function uh
which now what it will do is it will go
and check that whole api response and
check every single key in value to make
sure that
that is as we expect
um and you can use this all over the
place in form validation api requests uh
also on your back end is mostly where
it's used um and it's great and you can
now be certain when you
uh
use this in your application that it's
going to be passed around perfectly then
it will be perfect
but if you write this
you might hover over you might look at
the user the user and see i wonder what
type it is and it's
turns out to be this either type you
think uh what fred what is that
well
an either type is simply a type which
can represent a failure or a success and
the left is the failure the right is the
success so in this case if there's an
error right is would be user type
um
and how we kind of handle this in this
example
is we're just going to collapse that
down to one value when we return it
so
we're going to fold
how we do that we call this fold thing
fold method we get from uh fpts we
import from fpts and we fold the user
down and we have we say what do we do
when it's an error what do we do when
it's a success whatever return
so
what this looks like written out is when
it's a left an error we return a user
not found error when it's the user we
just return a user pretty simple and
then
this will return as a promise um to
to the consumer
now the second area i talked about
before
or um
wanted to look at was the promise
and i said that this doesn't really
encode
um doesn't really show that it's
functioning an error
well what would that look like with
under functional programming
well we had this eta type
we could just say this function returns
an ether
so now we say this function either
returns
uh either a success that's either an
error or a success which is an eye user
so
uh now we've kind of encoded into that
function contract that this this
function can error and so the consumers
one they can see that it errors and two
they're forced to handle it because of
how functional programming um happens
um but they
and so what we what they do oh and what
the function body looks like here is we
can actually just return that
that's either we get from the b code
to the to the consumer to the parent
and then you know if the thing is
they're they're informed that there's
this error but they don't have to handle
it they can also keep passing it up um
and they could just return like the
result of this um
function to their parent as well and so
on and there's there's various uh
ways that f various patterns that exist
to help you do this in a pretty elegant
way
briefly want to show that there's a
bunch of other types that exist in
functional programming
which have
relationships to javascript and
typescript um
and
there's even some types which kind of
represent behaviors which don't even
exist in javascript or typescript and so
you can
define your applications more
expressively with with functional
programming
um
but yeah that's that's been most of my
talk if you're interested and you want
to learn more i have a longer talk half
an hour long where i really go uh
somewhat in depth about how to build an
actual functional application and what
these kind of patterns look like and how
they help you
so go check it out um
and then also there's this five-minute
talk from robin mccorney when he talks a
little bit similar to what i've done
about form validation with fpts
there's also these two libraries
which
might help you integrate
fpts into your react
application um
and yeah
i wanted to take a moment to thank my
company imogex a sponsor of this
conference for letting me put on this
talk
and
personally i enjoy working imagex a lot
they're
a
a great team and there's some good
people on the team and
everyone really knows their stuff
and if you're interested in our service
come check out our booth um and you'll
get some account credit
otherwise that's been my talk i'm pretty
foggidy
uh and i wish you all the best of you
for the rest of your conference
take care
hi everybody
i'm matt billman co-founder and ceo of
netlify it's great to be back at the
react-a-thon this time in this online
virtual edition to talk about the jam
stack architecture and netlify our
end-to-end platform for managing modern
web properties
when we think about web properties 10
years ago if i had gone to most
designers and told them that today
uh their mean design tool will no longer
be a desktop application like photoshop
and illustrator it'll just be a url they
open in the browser they probably
wouldn't have believed me but with tools
like figma that's really becoming the
case office suites coding environment
the modern browser is an amazing
powerful platform that we can build deep
and engaging user experiences with
but traditionally to build these we've
had to manage provision
operate tons of infrastructure database
servers application servers web servers
load balancers cdn distribution setting
up caching rules to cash purchase
invalidations all of this
it's traditionally been a really complex
system to operate web properties at
scale
this is one of the things that we've
really worked to try to change with
netlify and with jamstack as an
architectural approach
the idea behind both notifying the
damstack is this idea of like how much
can we pre-build up front instead of
running this whole stack with all these
complex servers all this infrastructure
can we run a build step and then take
the output as a pre-built web
application a website and distribute it
to a cdn with nodes all over the world
and at nutify we really saw that if if
we could do that we could also tie it
into this git centric workflow that most
of us as developers have already adopted
working through branches pull requests
commits and so on and just expecting
that their deploys will flow to the edge
from each of those we also quickly
started seeing that content updates
could be pulled in during build time
from headless cmss like contentful or
sanity or cosmic and deployed directly
to the edge as well and build an
orchestration system for tying all of
that together the same even with data
updates a lot of those can be accessed
at build time pre-processed and deployed
globally
now
this approach
with the jam stack it's not just about
like building static sites from
different data sources and so on it's
really about a mental model where we
start reversing the traditional flow of
a web request response cycle so
with the traditional way we built web
applications every request from the
browser would go through this whole
stack of a request and response cycle
involving sometimes a cdn then passing
through to a web server an application
server that would then talk to all of
our apis and services to our main
database into our search cluster
generate html and then send that html
back to the browser
now
with the new sort of modern serverless
world of course we can keep the exact
same architecture we can run serverless
functions that just connect to our apis
and services to our database to our
search cluster and send to respond back
to back to the client and that's one way
of of using serverless but it comes with
all of the sort of traditional
trade-offs of this architecture and the
time it takes to go through this request
response cycle
with the jam stack approach we try to
really shorten the distance to the user
and sort of reverse the flow of the
request response cycle so instead of
having the browser talk to an
application server they'll talk to an
api on every request we try to just have
our pre-compute step our build service
that just talks to apis talk to
databases talk to our search cluster
pre-built as much as possible up front
and then send it out in advance to each
node and and this means that the actual
request to from from the user's browser
just hit an edge note get a pre-built
html site and and we'll get a response
to the user in milliseconds incredibly
fast great user experience now of course
we might still have a whole runtime we
might be building an application like
app.netlife.com
that we can't completely pre-build up
front
um but there's no reason that we
shouldn't just shorten the distance to
the apis and services as well why go
through that whole stack of cdns of load
balancers of web servers application
servers to talk to our apis and services
if we can just do it straight from the
browser all through the net its network
this allows some of these services like
algolia or fauna db or the like to in
themselves be globally distributed and
to the in themselves build really
advanced hard to imitate caching
infrastructures that will give the user
incredibly fast response times
now
for this build step where we pre-built
everything up front we've seen this
whole movement of different frameworks
and site generators emerge tools like
11c or scully for angular or next for
vue
hugo as a really fast scope-based
generator and
chapter grid sum next year is less like
if if you go to jamstack.org you can
find a massive list on them if we take
next year's as an example it's become
like a really important uh site
generator tool
and application framework for the for
the react community
it it allows you to group pages just
based on on the convention
and based on the name of your file it'll
generate like a pre-built page that we
can distribute directly to the edge at
build time um you can
fetch data at at build time through the
git static props method and and
we'll know that like we if you use
netlife netlife's build system will run
this it'll pre-build all the different
urls and distribute them with an atomic
deploy directly to the edge in handling
all the all the assets
now
traditionally when we had web servers we
didn't just use them to serve responses
we also had a set of of like sort of
typically declarative compute rules
around like routing rules redirect rules
rewrite rules and so on and on netlify
we will we allow you to do all of these
things directly at the edge as well
through our netlife counterfeit format
or our underscore redirects format again
we really tie into this git centric
workflow so it's this core idea that you
can just add a file to your repository
either in idlify tamil file or redirect
file this is just a really simple
example of a redirects file that just
defines simple like 301 redirects from
one destination to another this is an
example of a terminal redirect that's a
bit more complex that will say like
if the language of the end user is set
to english and the country is the united
states
then do this redirect and otherwise
don't do it so we can build like complex
localized version of our app and have
the edge nodes directly handle this
logic
apart from distributing these pre-built
html pages and running routing rules of
course sometimes you also have to
actually build custom api endpoint that
that your front end can talk to
sometimes you'll have services like
stripe that you can talk to directly but
often you might even even when you're
talking to those need a secret and need
something um that runs server side at
netlify we've we've embraced this
serverless paradigm in terms of
serverless functions where you can just
add a functions folder to your
repository and every file there will be
set up a with routing based on conveying
conventions so in this example we just
have a hello js they'll automatically
respond under dot netlife function slash
hello
now if you're using
next test you can also use these
functions to actually go back to sort of
the traditional server-side rendered
approach just by saying get server-side
props instead of get static props
you do the same cycle talk to your data
source
but by marking this as as get server
side props we'll actually like delegate
this to a server side function that will
generate the page you request on demand
this comes of course with a lot of the
same trade-offs that that we've had with
traditional server-side architectures we
can add layers of caching in front of it
and so on um but when you can you should
still try to see can we pre-build as
much as possible upfront that'll always
be the fastest the most secure
and the most predictable
sometimes you'll also need to run
background processes
in like let's let's take the
subscription example you might
have a have a function that's a quick
api endpoint that adds a new
subscriber to a plan but then
once you do that you might do a bunch of
steps you might send a new
email you might add them to a marketing
automation system and so on with netlify
we have a concept called background
functions and it's just as simple as
serp as serverless functions you just
append dash background to any function
and now when you trigger it instead of
immediately giving a response you'll
just trigger a background process that
can run up to 15 minutes great for
scheduled tests or these kind of
background operations that you do when
something happens
another really interesting aspect of
this architecture is again like this
edge layer where we just talked about
routing right like
language based versioning and so on
we also just that netify introduced a
new a new functionality that we talked
about as edge handlers
this is for when the declarative set of
routing rules just don't cut it let's
say you want to really build advanced
personalization or authentication based
on very detailed rules or you want to
build api gateway-like functionality
where you can route to authenticated
services directly from the edge node
with a netifies edge handlers you can
simply add an edge handlers folder to to
your git repository and start writing a
handlers just let you just like you
would write your
serverless functions
these can really intercept this request
response cycle
and you should typically use them for
things that you can do within a few
milliseconds again we don't want to go
back to this old style architecture of
everything being part of a very long
request response cycle but for example
let's say you just want to check an
authorization header if someone access a
secret part of your site and you want to
do some custom logic in in in response
to that this would be a little exchanger
that you could write that that do this
imagine you want to serve like a
specific set of javascript a specific
bundle of javascript
to mobile browsers and another one to
desktop browsers i don't recommend this
but you would totally write an and an
edge handler that would just look at the
user agent and then decide which bundle
version to serve in directly from the
edge network
so just to put these different pieces
together like when you build with the
jam stack and when you build on netlify
the types of primitives we offer is
first of all the pre-compute layer
that's really our build service you can
run a long process here that can stitch
together hundreds of thousands of html
pages and our service will push the ones
that change directly to the edge and
prepare them there
these will deliver be delivered to the
end user almost instantly and it's
always sort of the fastest the most
secure the most the the simplest to
reason about that you can do
then we have this layer of routing and
transformations that split between like
our declarative route engine in tunnel
files so underscore redirects and then
edge handlers where you can fully
program the edge layer
then there's the serverless functions
that can run in a few seconds like
typically great for api in point micro
services or glue layer or even for
server-side rendering like with get
server-side props in next and then
background functions for when you need
compute that takes longer when you don't
want to be trapped inside a request
response cycle when you want to trigger
a job and just run it in the background
do actions
and and trigger requests
as you can see like at netlify we're
really building out this whole platform
around the jamstack architectural
approach that makes it incredibly easy
to write
great user experiences with great
performance without ever having to
work with um
operating servers maintaining
infrastructure or thinking about complex
deployment systems or pipelines
you just work in kit you follow a few
clear conventions and our platform will
take care of all of the operations and
infrastructure for you
if you're interested specifically in in
how we handle next year's is since this
is so focused on react and next year's
is of course really popular in the react
world right now go to netlify.com slash
with slash next years and reach read
much more about it thank you so much
have a great rest of the conference
hi my name is max i'm a software
engineer at flexport today i'll be
talking about how we streamline mobile
development using react native and expo
there'll be four sections first some
background
then three deep dives into different
areas where we're using these tools
um to improve our development lifecycle
so a little bit of context
flexport is a freight forwarder we help
facilitate the movement of large
shipments of cargo across the world this
is an example of an ocean container
moving from an origin factory to a
destination warehouse the section on the
right with the green
uh shows destination trucking and that's
where our mobile app is being used this
part of the shipment life cycle is
really important for our customers
because
it's when their warehouses need to get
ready to prepare to receive the cargo
and then package it and send it out to
customers of theirs
so to help facilitate
gathering data
on this section of the lifecycle we
built
products called transmission
transmission is a software suite that
trucking carriers can use to manage
their fleets internally as well as to
provide updates to flexport and flexpose
clients
and so this mobile screen these mobile
screenshots so what this is like for a
driver or one of these trucking carriers
they can enter a container number and
then provide
pickup and delivery events and then this
data is useful both for flexport and
also for the trucking carrier because
the trucking carrier can see data like
where their truckers are at a given time
when they're due back
things like that
and so transmission is an important part
of our ecosystem for managing
destination trucking but i included this
slide because i want to show that it's
not the only thing that we're working on
in this area so you can see that on the
bottom
containers are going from ocean ports
sometimes to rail terminals and then
filing to client warehouses
we have a lot of different data sources
including ocean carriers terminals api
integrations we built apps for the
warehouses
and so we're doing a lot of different
stuff to get this data and the mobile
app is just one of the things we're
doing
and so
this is one of the reasons we decided
upon using react native is because we
can increase the leverage of our team
writing one code base in javascript that
we're familiar with
and deploying native mobile apps to both
android and ios
really really awesome
expo
allows us to make changes to these
applications and deploy them to our
clients phones
without needing to
make binaries and go through the app
store approval process and things like
that so it's much easier to add small
features change copy fix bugs that sort
of thing using exposed deployment
lifecycle
so we expected these benefits going in
but the thing that we were surprised by
is how much
is possible to build on top of
expo's um
javascript bundle management system
for our own internal tooling and so
that's what these next three
features we'll highlight so the first is
the mobile sandbox
so some context here is we have at
flexport internally something called the
web sandbox so here you can
push a feature branch to get
to github
and then
take your branch name put it into a
sandbox tool
and then launch a version of our web app
running within obfuscated development
database
and uh
but kind of fully functional
and
and then share share that with customers
ems designers things like that
um and get feedback on it before you
merge into master so here you can see
that this is a pull request from a few
years ago it used to be called staging
instead of sandbox but there's a url
generated for your branch in particular
that anyone can load
internally on the vpn um to test things
out so you wanted something similar like
this for mobile
but it turns out it's not a one-to-one
mapping because with web
there's a
client code running in a browser right
we have a wrapped front end and there's
server code running on aws there's a
rails back-end
and so when we push the sandbox for web
code we just push
the front end and back-end code to a
single server and then when the client
code running in the browser fetches the
javascript bundle to run the web app
it's fetching the code from your branch
but
with mobile
the react native front end code isn't
coming from our backend it's coming from
the mobile app stores in the form of
downloaded app binaries as well as from
expo's bundle servers where expo is
sending javascript bundles to the phones
to change behavior on the phones and
that's where most of our business logic
is leading
and so
if we want to create something like a
sandbox
we it's insufficient to just push the
front end code to the same server as the
back end code so we ended up doing is
using exposed servers and creating
different release versions of the app
for each sandbox that makes it possible
to replicate the sandbox experience on
um
on mobile
and so the code is something like this
it's like hey deploy the sandbox
um
set this mobile app to talk to this
particular sandbox back-end
publish the mobile app
and then
you can see that's just standard we're
just running the standard expo cli
commands but we're doing it in kind of a
programmatic way
and so the experience from a developer's
perspective is you can just check this
box i want a mobile
sandbox
and then you'll get a link to expo and
you can paste the qr code into your pull
request your designer or pm can review
it there
so really cool feature and it's just
something we were very we were able to
build on top of xbox javascript bundles
automatic deployment so
for web we have continuous deployment
every time we commit to master we're
taking off the deploy pipeline um
we wanted something similar for mobile
um
we built one
so we have two versions of the operating
one is production and one is release
candidate and so the release candidate
one
is these are this is unlike the sandbox
in the sandbox we're just using separate
um release
channels within the same expo project
but here we actually have two server
expo projects two separate app binaries
two separate listings in the stores we
actually have four store listings total
um android and ios and then prod and our
prod and rc for each of those
and so our continuous deployment
pipeline every hour is cutting
master building the javascript bundle
pushing it to expo and then for
production we're using a similar
code path but you have to click the
button to do it just because we don't
want to be doing that
every time there's a commit
and so
the architecture here is like we have
you can have a phone
running both the prod app and the rc app
because there's separate listings in the
app store
and then get updates independently
and they are both they're both talking
to the rails backing so it's production
light in that sense
so the code for this is you know running
in our in our deployment pipeline and
it's it's similar so build the mobile
app publish the expo you'll notice the
release channel is default here
and then we persist the app manifest
i'll talk more about that in a second
but first i want to talk about why the
release channel is default
that's because in our code base in
master
the
javascript uh the configuration of the
expo app is for the release candidate so
this is what the source code looks like
everything is released candidate
and so
the default release candidate release
channel for expo is the thing that has
our javascript code for
so when we push to production the code
is a little bit different we send some
slack alerts which are useful and then
we set production values in app.json
that basically takes the master code you
see here
and then replaces release candidate with
production so this way we have one
version of our app.json checked into
master no one is ever manually editing
this or trying to keep it in sync
between release candidate and production
instead as part of our build pipeline we
programmatically update the values into
app.json and then we build the app
push it to
the default release channel for the slug
transmission production in this case
and then persist the out manifest and so
this is it just feels very clean and
there's only one way to push to
production and that's using our built-in
pipeline and it does these things in a
programmatic way so there's no risk of
manual messing up
so the mobile app manifest has data
about the version that was pushed to
expo and we persist this in our database
and i'll talk about why that's useful in
a second
so here's a quick screenshot of the um
slack notification
so what do we do with the persisted data
we prompt users to upgrade so we can ask
users hey
um
your app is out of date please upgrade
and it's kind of an optional thing they
can still use the app but there's a
spanner up top
or if we are like
really you know we see a bug in a
previous version or there's some new
functionality that we really need all
users to have
we can block access to the app and say
hey you have to upgrade this to keep
using it
and so here's some of the code in our
configuration for this
and then we prompt users to do upgrading
and we can prompt not only to upgrade
binaries but also to prompt update the
javascript bundles if it's just like a
lightweight refresh so in that case a
user can tap this thing
tap the red banner it'll just refresh
the app they'll get the latest
javascript bundle good to go
um
and
so all of this stuff was just very easy
to layer on top of expo's manifest
system
and so
hopefully this is useful to others uh we
really like using these tools check out
this blog post if you have any questions
i want to give a shout out to some of my
teammates derek and yongfu for helping
to work on these features
thanks
i was waking up
the rest of my life
to see
nothing else matters on great days
i've been waiting all day to let you
i want to stay know forever
is
the space between us
is
hi everyone
my name is benjamin dunphy and i'm the
organizer of
react-a-thon and i just wanted to
personally welcome you to react-a-thon
online worldwide
you know
when i started react-a-thon back in
2017
i could have
never imagined
the amazing community we would have
built
and i also could not have imagined
what has happened here in 2020
and so i want to thank you
for
your understanding
for your patience
and for your trust
as we move this event
online
to a remote worldwide safe
atmosphere
as we wait the next
in-person event where we can all
come together
until then
please enjoy react-a-thon online
worldwide 2020.
have a great conference everyone
hello everyone
welcome welcome welcome
we're here we're worldwide we are coming
at you through the interwebs
and we are so excited to be here with
you today my name is anjana vakil i'm
going to be one of your mcs for the next
few days i'm a software developer and
developer advocate at observable really
excited to be here uh coming at you from
san francisco today
jonathan oh i'm sorry
we've got a little bit of a
tiny delay i think because i'm in
tennessee uh so we have just that little
bit of latency so you might see that
amongst other things my name is jonathan
catrell
i am a director of engineering at pbs i
am also the host of a podcast called
developer t
and i will also be an emcee over the
next couple of days we're very excited
for everything that's getting ready to
happen
you know this has been a difficult year
for everybody probably everybody who's
connected to uh to the to the conference
today has their own story about 2020 and
uh it's been a unique year it's it's
come with its challenges challenges
always make us better but we're not
going to focus on the challenges for
this
for this conference instead we're going
to focus on kind of geeking out together
about react and uh the various kind of
things around the react world
and there are people around the world
who are connected
to this conference today and we're
really excited about it
yeah
we are super excited to have you all
here with us today we are also really
grateful to the sponsors that make this
event the next few days possible so we
just want to give a huge shout out and
thank you to our sponsors flexport
course hero
imagex verso
off xero hasera vonage netlify and mux
thank you so much
and if you didn't get a chance to hang
out with our sponsors already at their
expo boost this morning you'll have
other opportunities to do so
this afternoon and over the next two
days we encourage you to go and learn
from them and uh it's it's not just
because they're the sponsors and we want
them to be happy with us as a conference
is because they have some of the world's
top engineers uh and and some of the
hottest companies in the bay area but
also with remote work uh around the
world so make sure you go and check
those out by the way we're on a platform
called hop in
uh this is a a new way of doing uh
conferences for a lot of us but i
encourage you to go and click around a
little bit there's a lot to learn
uh about hop in i guess there's not a
lot to learn there's a lot to explore i
guess is a better way to put it it's
pretty easy to use
but certainly don't sit back if you're
just sitting back and watching the talks
you're not going to get all that you can
out of this conference
there's a lot that we can and we'll talk
about it a little bit more in the kind
of interim between the talks as well and
you know suggest that you go to certain
parts of hop-in but definitely go and
check out those uh sponsor expos
yeah absolutely and again we are all
really excited to have you all here with
us uh virtually with us in hoppin the
really great thing about hopin is that
it allows us all attendees at the
conference speakers mcs everybody around
the uh react-a-thon world to be able to
connect and get to know each other and
there's even some cool features you can
explore like to be randomly paired uh to
meet somebody just like you would maybe
bumping into them at a sponsor booth or
uh in line for the bathroom between the
talks at a
irl conference so we're hoping that
hopit allows us to all connect in the
best way that we can uh given the
virtual constraints of our environment
here so really really thankful to all of
you who are here with us today
whether you're joining us live in hopin
or whether you're tuning in through the
live stream hello
and we are super super grateful
especially to everybody who was planning
to attend react-a-thon in san francisco
back in march i know i was and has been
waiting the better part of a year uh for
this uh really exciting new addition to
happen so we could not be more thrilled
to have everybody here together today
in the constraints of our virtual world
but we do need to keep in mind that we
are still all in a community so jonathan
is going to give us a special update
about uh
how we can be mindful of each other's
experience
yeah there's there's an excellent
way that we can kind of come together
and uh and hold each other accountable
and that's a code of conduct you know
it's a very explicit thing that we have
in real life conferences and this is no
different we want to respect each other
whether we're behind a screen or not so
there is a code of conduct the tldr is
please be considerate respectful and
take responsibility for your actions
and please read the full code of conduct
at
reactathon.com conduct
yeah and we want to make sure that this
just like an in-person conference would
be that this is a really safe welcoming
learning focused environment uh for
everyone so in that interest we want to
make sure that if anyone if you ever
feel unsafe harassed
or someone is trolling or otherwise
making your conference experience
unpleasant or unsafe you can reach out
to the organizer so that we can
act on that so if you find someone is
harassing you or making your experience
unsafe in hop in there's actually a
feature you can click on their profile
and you would have an option to report
user when you do that the conference
organizers will receive a report which
then they can investigate and take the
necessary actions as per the code of
conduct so once again please make sure
to check out the code of conduct at
reactathon.com
conduct
and here's the great thing we have three
days of content
three days of amazing content and
networking learning education it's all
planned for you
and each of these uh days follow a
similar format that anjana is going to
talk about
yeah so as you uh have already seen
we're going to start out the day with
some morning workshops and then a
sponsor expo we're going to hear a
little bit some from some sponsors and
there'll be time for everybody to reach
out to each other and do some networking
on the hop-in platform also talk to the
sponsors visit their booths all that
good stuff and just get yourself really
excited for the rest of the day which is
going to consist of some stage talks on
the morning and jonathan and i will be
here with you on the stage uh for all
three days uh to to guide us all through
it
and we will also have following those
stage talks we will have 90-minute topic
table sessions with experts and speakers
and folks who you can connect with more
directly around specific topics of
interest
then at the end of the day we're going
to cap things off with another hour of
some stage talks to really make sure
that our brains are chock full of new
ideas and exciting information uh when
we leave at the end of the day
so that is what our next few days are
gonna look like but jonathan i think
we've been yapping and we should just uh
you know get this show on the road as
they say what do you think yeah it's
time to hand time to hand the stage over
to our first
guest for the day
guillermo rauch uh guillermo is the
founder and ceo of versailles uh he is
uh the co-creator of now uh if you've
ever used now if you haven't it was
pretty awesome uh and next js and former
cto and the co-founder of learn boost
and cloud up acquired by wordpress in
2013
he created the first mongodb orm for
node.js
uh and mongoose.js before that he was a
core developer of the mootools
javascript framework that's a throwback
if there ever was one and he's been
working on react since its early days
all right and and here's the cool thing
he's gonna share with you a post jam
stack uh talk today uh the post jam
stack world and the rise of hybrid
frameworks yes so please join us in
welcoming guillermo rauch for the
opening keynote of react-a-thon
worldwide
hello everybody uh this is guillermo and
i'm really excited to be here with you
today hope you're all staying safe
i'm here to talk about today about the
post gemstock world
and what that entails and the rise of
uh hybrid frameworks like
nexjs
so
i like to start by contextualizing kind
of uh
the state that we're in today and the
problems that we're solving and perhaps
starting with a little bit of a green
message but
later on turns really optimistic i
promise which is that the web is in
jeopardy
and
to illustrate that i look back to 2018
uh really interesting tweet that i
have since kind of memorized almost
which talks about
the this website usa today
and this gentleman gentlemen marcel went
ahead and did a before and after
performance audit
by just removing a lot of junk from that
website
a lot of unnecessary javascript requests
a lot of unnecessary downloads a lot of
unnecessary craft
and yes he did remove the gdpr banner
but that's not really entirely what's
wrong with it
so what he found is that before it would
take an akitio nod 14 000 milliseconds
so that's 14 seconds to get to the first
paint of this
usa today website
and after removing everything pretty
much other than the text
and we'll get into why this concept of
craft or additional js is important or
not later in the presentation
he found that he could bring everything
down to
three seconds
so he went uh from a load time of uh 45
seconds to three seconds so
this is why i think the web is in
jeopardy and by the way this was in 2018
but
the situation has really not gotten a
lot better since
because if you look at the progression
of key metrics like first content full
paint and on load
and largest content in full paint which
is a metric that hasn't merged most
recently it's pretty much it's gotten
better for sure but it's pretty much
been a very slow
improvement and when it comes down to
metrics like first contentful paint and
largest content for paint we don't see
that
big of a difference so we would hope
and that's where that's what really this
presentation is all about is
i think we can make this a lot better
but we need to understand the problem
fully and we need to attack it in the
best possible way with the best possible
tools
and with the best possible approaches
and before i go too much further i think
something that perhaps not a lot of
presentations go into
which is this concept of
what do we mean exactly by the web right
like
we obviously all talk about it but
there's three properties that i think
about when i think about the web that i
would love personally to see
improve and a lot of
organizations and businesses and
individuals i think throughout the world
would love to see improvement one of the
key things is that this web is global
so when we look at the data for
how
things have changed in terms of
performance over the past few years
and we look at you know this orange bar
line at the top we'll see that
india
is possibly you know twice as bad as for
example south korea in this case
um
and interestingly enough india is where
a lot of the growth is a lot of where
the best tech companies and unicorns
have been created it's where a lot of
the
people are coming online so this matters
a lot
and interestingly enough that web that
i'm talking about is also increasingly
mobile
right so i like to talk about this more
recent uh data point which i found uh
from
josh camille
where he talks about you know the most
common device in the world today and
guess what
that device is not the iphone 12 pro max
super m1 duper it's
actually more like this phone that you
see on the screen here which is a
xiaomi redmi 8 and it's the most common
budget smartphone in india which is
one of these key areas that we're taking
a look at
and
one of the things he finds
is
that the web side by side so on the
right hand side you have an iphone and
on the left you have this xiaomi redmi
average indian smartphone
so you can see that there's quite a bit
more spinning
on this website on the left and that's
a very very optimized website with a lot
of resources behind it that in this case
happens to put up
almost entirely on the client side right
so it's not something that has compre
rendered from a server which will get
into the benefits of it later
and actually that's still pretty good
because all things considered because
he goes on to say things get problematic
when we visit news sites
and i think because of all the tracking
snippets and such it's a pretty good
guess
these sites take forever so here's the
new york times and before we go on uh
for a lot of those of you
that have already in your personal
experience identified this problem with
the web because we all notice that when
we just use the web every day uh yes
this is gonna be a little painful to
watch so let's take a look so he's
tapping
on on a story here
and you can see on the right hand side
that actually still took pretty long for
my liking personally but notice that on
the left and speaking and is still going
uh so this is kind of the reality of
today right like you can you can buy one
of these phones on amazon and run this
test yourself and what we're taking a
look at here is a what
in our minds
uh in in an oversimplified model we
could say well this is a super simple
website right it's just like
it's literally an online newspaper how
how could it be like this right
so he goes on to make a lot of
interesting observations one of them is
that ad heavy wordpress sites and like
modern web apps seem to be really really
bad for him so it's actually an
interesting concept there like the idea
of ads and third-party scripts
then he mentions every major
react tab and we're going to get into
why this idea of that major react app
happens to be really relevant here since
it's either server rendered
or other forms of pre-generation so
he notices that that boot up time is
actually not bad he does mention the
time to interactive is slow
and we certainly need to fix that
so another great observation there and
he says that next js for example
has
done a lot here because nexjs in
particular
offers both server rendering and
pre-rendering so
gatsby's more focused on the latter but
he says that that's a property that is
making that web feel faster especially
when you first load the page
and the the third property i think about
when i think about what is the web to me
is that and it goes into this concept of
he makes the observation that major
websites built with react are not as bad
is that the web is not all
evenly distributed
nor
build a like
so another interesting tweet that came
from one of the team members of the
google chrome turned me to this idea of
what does the traffic distribution of
the web look like
and this is why i use the dragon emoji
is that i try to find an animal that
both had a very long tail
and b
had a lot of potential that we can
unleash so
one of the key insights from this
telemetry that came from google chrome
is that the head of the web which is
just 10 websites
represents 33 of global page views
and those are actually discrete page
rendering so we're not thinking traffic
here because we've probably heard the
data like netflix has tons of the
internet's bandwidth or whatever this is
in particular pages so where are you
opening a web browser to go to
and then the tours of the web which is a
lot of other websites
in particular
10 000 so the body of this
dragon the torso is 10 000 that's also
33
and then what's kind of interesting is
that the long tail of the web is up to 3
million websites depending on the device
and that represents 33 so just
torso and head which is not that many
websites represent 50
so if you consider like the top thousand
actually that's like
the head and a little bit more that's 50
and if you consider head and torso
entirely that's you know nearly 66 or so
so
what's interesting too is that if you
correlate it with if you go and look how
these things are built you start
noticing a pattern or a trend that i
think is really interesting in the
context of thinking about jam stack
which is
the static web is more of the realm of
that like long tail
where
there's more individual creators or
perhaps you know you fire and forget you
build it or perhaps you use some sort of
um
static generation tool and you just not
updated as frequently and for example
like
long build times don't matter as much
but then as you start traversing into
the more
you know heavy traffic web we know it's
actually the opposite it's super dynamic
lots and lots of pages you could never
possibly build them all in in a build
process through ci cd
and also we notice that it's hyper
personalized so
each user is getting a different page so
there's not much that's a static there
and that correlates a lot with what
we're seeing in terms of that you know
where people are spending time and what
technology is best suited for that
so
in conclusion the larger the site
the more likely that performance matters
a lot right because like if you're the
new york times you're everywhere
and you have a big business at stake
and then
and unfortunately what we're seeing from
all this from the data and the anik data
so the things that users are reporting
or recording
performance is not really that great
that great
so this made me think i'll spend a lot
of time thinking about like okay what is
the difference between
this monster diamond and called fagozon
uh it's pretty cool i hope i'm an
inventor of that so what's the
difference between that fagozon
uh so this top 10 websites that
seemingly have figured it all out
they're both dynamic and super
performant
and they keep evolving fearlessly and
their page loads are fast so what's the
difference between them
and the rest of the web and
some of the conclusions that we found is
that if you look at like for example
how they consider front-end development
they have lots of teams supporting
fairly advanced front infrastructure
and they have a unified approach a
unified framework a lot of automation
um it when it comes down to go into
production that's also very much
automated so the front end developer
doesn't have to figure out
the production environment and they can
usually
reproduce that production environment
really well throughout the development
process and they're assisted by a lot of
data
and finally
there's this idea of reusing so reusing
components reusing design systems and
learning from the past so there's a lot
of
um sort of intelligence and historical
data has been built up because frankly
those top ten have had a lot of you know
uh a lot a bit of a head start no pun
intended because they've been around for
so long
so to fix it we i think we can take a
page and we can learn from this so
what we're trying to do uh in our
company is give you the framework that
unified front-end infrastructure
solution that unified tooling that
continues to get improved without you
having to deal with webpack
configurations and other implementation
details
in a platform that you can fearlessly
evolve the evolution of your front end
in through
preview deployments
constant benchmarking
testing your site and results in a real
production environment a global cdn and
so on
and one of the things that we notice as
well is that nexus demonstrated that it
has
quite a bit of a fit
specifically in this
top
segment of the web this most common side
so once we're frankly you want to spend
the most time optimizing because like i
said number one
they have a reason to constantly invest
in better performance and their
performance is not there yet
so our approach consists in
wrapping react which gives you this
incredible unit of collaboration in the
component
so you build a component
and you can reuse it and your entire
team benefits from every improvement
that you make to that component i like
to call it the lego brick of the web
then you can constantly preview your
front and so every time you push to get
when you import your project into
versailles you get a url you can see it
here
at the shop get new checkout url
and you can share that with the rest of
your team and then when you ship
everything around performance has
already been figured out automatically
for the entire team
but most importantly what we've noticed
what we've been noticing is that even
though our motto is developed previous
ship
it really is in this iteration phase and
collaboration phase where a lot of the
value in making the web better really
resides
and when it comes down to iteration and
when it comes down to understanding
performance deeply i think one of the
most important things is to have
a very very good lens of the reality of
the state of your front ends and your
websites
so the common expectation that i've seen
sometimes in the ecosystem is
okay so
this is the sort of the image
of the web and
i know that if i have a cdn that
will ensure that everything is fast and
especially if it's been pre-rendered or
statically generated it's all good it's
fast
and then i think the only thing i need
to do is figure out the size of my js
bundle which that is like the other big
thing there's only there's these two
things is that i have a fast cdn i use
jam stack static generation whatever and
as long as i don't have a lot of js in
the client side i'm good
reality however is
really quite different from that
oversimplified model that a lot of us
used to have in the past
so a cdn nowadays is kind of table
stakes most websites nowadays have it
and we go to great lengths to automate
it and make it available and free for
you
but then performance becomes quite an
interesting subject quite an interesting
rabbit hole i'd like to start with this
example of box shadow because
when facebook rewrote their
facebook.com in the latest and greatest
technologies in 2020 using
react and for the first time they were
using the entirety of react very similar
to how nexjs works where the entire page
is driven by react whereas in their past
it used to be a combination of php and
legacy technology and all that
so a gentleman went ahead and started
doing what every web developer does
right we inspect the open web so they
went ahead and like took a look at like
how this new facebook thing was being
built
and this gentleman ahmad noticed
that
the background at the very top
was not box shadow with css it was
actually a background image
yes so the new facebook
this experts of the web the creators of
react in 2020 were using an image which
for
all of you that have been using the web
for many many years like myself you
remember that this is how we used to do
this like 10 to 15 years ago because we
didn't have the box shadow properly so
they're they're sort of going back and
why was that so
one of the
performance engineers at facebook uh
graciously
uh noted that it's for performance a box
shadow in the floating header like that
was killing scroll performance in
browsers
and mateos goes ahead and asked so i
don't know if this is a question but how
do you guys test that
and this again we're like expectation
reality or a little bit um uh not what
we expect which is
honestly you just scroll the page and
you would notice so like i said teams
like facebook spend a lot of time
worrying about performance and obviously
they get great results from that and
sometimes it's very sophisticated and
sometimes it's very
much
that good old
you know feeling test
so and here's why i'd like to use this
image of the iceberg which is
this mass of complexity that we tend to
ignore in our oversimplified models has
so many things that contribute to
performance like the latest web font
that you copied and pasted from
somewhere in the web
with lots of css files and js files and
so on your gdpr pop-up that comes from
some third-party script and your
marketing team as an analytics script
and then your product teams as analytics
script and
as uh
josh was mentioning earlier the
ads and trackers play a big role in
exception reporting scripts
and session recording scripts for
product teams and images
and
your js bundle
and i think here's where
you know the solution
which that tweet from usa today was kind
of alluding to
is where also i think we have to be on
the side of reality which is
it's very easy to say well just throw
all that away and then your website will
be fast and i'm actually willing to bet
that that would be the case for the most
part if you throw all that away
then i'm sure your website would be fast
but then
i think these things got there not
because we're intending to make the web
slow
but because we didn't have the right
workflow
in many cases we didn't have the right
tools so for example if you now use the
nexjs image component that image which
was a big part of the iceberg because
for example you were giving a gigantic
image that was unoptimized to a very
small screen now that gets fixed
so
um it's not that you had to remove the
image instead of how to make it optimal
and
and that's where my sort of
perception here is you have to focus on
real solutions deleting them deleting
all that sounds good but it's not very
realistic for most businesses
and one of the solutions really ends up
being
the
good all
cloud computing and i like to use this
stock photo that i found in google
images because
notice that like the cloud is
streaming ones and zeros to a screen
which is actually pretty different from
how the actual cloud works but it's a
good metaphor for okay
instead of trying to
run everything on my device perhaps i
can start doing some things at different
times i can start doing some things
earlier in the life cycle i could do
them
on the edge i could do them on my server
i could do it at build time sometimes
and then it begins sort of a streaming
one
one unified
painting of the web that i want to
deliver
so one of the strategies here that's
quite obvious is okay so instead of
doing competition the device shifted to
the cloud so all those spinners that we
saw
when the app was booting up on a slower
device would have happened on a more
powerful device
a more powerful
literally machinery in the cloud
so and this is where for example
combining and starting to introduce
server rendering or server less
rendering like in our case where you
define a page that is not static and is
also not deferring all the computation
to the client side but instead we
leverage
this asymmetry of computing right
because the computing on on the cloud is
more powerful than the one on the device
and this is really what the new
generation of hybrid frameworks are
enabling so
next knox and zveltkit are examples of
frameworks that can say well
yes this one page is a static but this
other page can also do server rendering
so you're not locked in
to a local maxima to a peak of
performance that could be done with
static generation
and you're only out outlet it's not just
to put everything on the device is to
also put it where it belongs
and this also comes from the conclusion
realization that your cdn is not enough
right so
that time to first buy that that
connection to a to a city and edge and
getting some html there is a very
simplistic view of the problem and it's
very limited and it's not how we're
going to accomplish great performance
one of the ways that we can do this
because
server rendering is also not a silver
bullet or just saying well i'm just
going to use a hybrid framework i'm done
that's also not the right solution so
when when i mentioned the post gems at
world and the rise of hybrid frameworks
i'm not saying well just use a framework
that comes with all these batteries
included
you'll have to measure continuously as
well but this is why next js is also
focusing on
not just giving you for example a better
image component
that optimizes that part of the iceberg
and we have tons of other efforts
ongoing for optimizing a lot of the
other parts of that mass of ice
but one of the things we wanted to do
early on is
put you on a workflow and give you a
workflow
where you constantly get feedback about
how you're doing but from the
perspective of the real world so we call
this a real experience score and what we
do essentially is
we take
a subset of the same inputs that
lighthouse uses when you do a synthetic
manual test
but we collect them from your devices
and then we give you a picture of like
how well you're performing across mobile
desktop how you're doing across
different countries how you're doing
across different dimensions so this is
gonna
help you
for example not ship that box shadow
because then perhaps it was slowing you
down
and like i said the nice thing is that
it's integrated into
the nexus
data source so we know for example what
pages and we can help you find out what
pages are contributing to the different
breakdowns of scores
and what's really cool is that it's not
just unique to next.js so
we are working to enable this for all
frameworks starting with gatsby and more
are coming very soon where for example
if you import your gatsu project into
versailles you're gonna start getting a
lot of these benefits of continuously
thinking about performance from the
perspective of your real users
so all that said does it mean gemsec is
bad doesn't mean that putting a lot of
like that j that encourages putting
javascript in the client is bad no i
don't think so i think it really depends
on what you're building and it really
depends on what are your ambitions are
ambitions are
and furthermore it's not just that
gemsec is not bad is that a lot of the
ideas that were
built in into that stack like the idea
that the markup the m can be cached at
the edge
and that you should leverage a lot of
pre-rendering that's a great tool as
well
and you can start there for example in
his you can make some of your pages
completely gems and completely static
and then you can combine it with a
performance-oriented workflow where
you're analyzing your metrics
and you're really starting to ascertain
if it makes sense for you or not but you
also always have that possibility of
adding more
so my advice in that regard is you can
use subsets of these ideas whenever
possible so when you define your pages
you say well this one is a static and
nexus automates all that so you don't
have to say well for this build process
i built statically and then i wrap it
with a server and cache and purge so the
beauty of it is too that
you really have to
just define your pages and you're off to
the races
and
again it's all about not limiting what
you can do or how good your performance
can be
if you want to learn more about nexjs
and
learn how this hybrid capabilities work
you can go to nexus.org learn
and later
in in the conference lee robinson will
be talking about specifically how this
page generation and data fetching
components of flexjs that enable
pre-rendering server rendering and much
more work
and you can deploy all kinds of front
ends whether fully static and jump stack
or the new generation of hybrid
technologies you can deploy to the
versailles for free
and by the way you also get the ability
to measure continuously so
it the the
journey doesn't end at just deploying
but it really
ends with and continues with learning
from your users and
ensuring that they're happy no matter
where they are in the world
thank you so much and i hope you have a
great rest of your conference
awesome
i always love you amazing uh
it's it's so good to hear guillermo uh
in these discussions
uh performance is such an important
thing so uh please go back and re-watch
that talk um these are going to be
available after the conference but now
we're going to move into our next
section
our lightning talks these are four talks
in less than 15 minutes i love lightning
talks what do you think boom boom boom
boom can't wait to hear some of these
great lightning talks that we're about
to dig into here
and following the lightning talks we're
going to break up into topic tables so
we can get up and close and personal in
live sessions with some of these
speakers and sponsors and some of the
instructors of the workshops as well and
other folks that we just can't wait to
connect with so more on that and how
that's all going to go after the
lightning talks but first first up first
up yeah is uh lydia holly um
lydia is is uh an independent software
engineer and you can see her work at the
avocado.com
that's like
avocado uh
with er at the end i guess yes um she
will be explaining and visualizing the
life of a script for us and it gets
really technical and really cool and the
visuals are awesome so please stick
around for this awesome lightning talk
with lydia alley
i'm lydia halley and today i'm going to
give you a pretty like high level
walkthrough of basically everything that
happens going from our human friendly
javascript file all the way down to
something that computers can understand
and they're like there are so many parts
to this process but for now i'm only
going to focus on two things namely the
browser side of things and v8 side of
things and v8 is the javascript engine
used in chromium-based browsers and in
node as well first let's go all the way
back to the beginning so we're trying to
load a website that uses a small calc.js
script and as we're trying to load the
website the html parser encounters a
script tag and tries to fetch the
calc.js file from either of the network
or maybe cache or a service worker that
prefetched a file either way a stream of
bytes get returned that gets sent to the
bytestream decoder relaxer and this is
part of the parser that takes care of
decoding the stream of bytes and
generating tokens based on the data it
received for example it sees that the
bytes decode to f-u-n-c-t ion it
generates a token say like hey i know
this function is a keyword in javascript
and it creates a token based on that and
it'll just continue to do so for the
rest of the stream as well and as it's
generating these tokens is actually
sending them all down to the parser and
the parser then goes ahead and creates
notes based on the tokens that match a
certain syntax rule in javascript
for example a variable declaration or a
function statement and based on these
notes a parser generates an abstract
syntax tree that represents our program
now this one is uh very much simplified
because in real life it also contains
some extra information about a program
but for now this will suffice um and
also while it's doing that it's checking
for syntax errors because the tokens
themselves may be valid but maybe they
may not actually match a certain syntax
rule finally it's time for the
javascript engine to do its work because
this est is actually sent down to v8's
ignition interpreter and this
interpreter is responsible for
generating the bytecode that it based on
the ast that it received
and we can actually see the bytecode
that gets generated with the print
bytecode flag in node so for example
this bytecode for our calc function
if we invoke it with an object
containing an xy and z key it would look
something like this and this may seem
like a lot of data but there's actually
only two parts here that are really
important so ignition uses registers in
order to execute the bytecode and
there's registers like r0 and r1 but
there's also an accumulated register
that the byte codes use for their input
and output or both
and then there's also registers like a0
that are used for the values that got
passed to the function and this makes
more sense as we're walking through the
bytecode don't worry
so in this case we passed an object
containing an x y and z key to the
function so this is where the second
part of the generated output is
important because a0 points to a shape
table that contains information on where
to find those properties on the object
that we pass to the function
all right so now let's see what those
bytecodes actually do so in the very
first line we see lda named property by
code so lda specifies that a value gets
loaded into the accumulator and that the
value is the named property from the
object that we passed to the function
stored in a0 and the property itself can
be found on index 0. so we see that the
value on index 0 maps to x so we load
the value of the x property of the
object that we passed the function so
the numeric value 10 in this case
then we multiply the current value in
the accumulator by the small integer 50.
and then star r0 specifies that the
current value of the accumulator has to
get stored in register r0
then again we load a property and store
this into the accumulator but this time
it's from the second index which points
to y and y has a value of 20. so the
value of the accumulator is now 20 and
star 2 specifies again that the current
value of the accumulator has get stored
in register r2 we again load a named
property from a1 or sorry a0 into the
accumulator
the value in the third index this time
which maps to z has a value of 30. so we
multiply the current value of the
accumulator with the value that's
currently stored in register r2
so one more step we have to add the
values to it and register r0 to the
current value of the accumulator so this
means that we're adding 500 plus 600 is
1100 and finally we return the value of
the accumulator which is 1100. now the
bytecode that is generated by the
bytecode generator also goes through
some smaller optimizations after which
the bytecode actually gets executed and
it's possible to run this on our
machines so finally we have something
that our machines can work with now you
may have noticed that i skipped some
things in a bytecode um
so let's see what's up with them this is
actually part of v8 optimizations
because when we pass an object to v8
such as the x y and z object in this
case it creates a shape for that
specific object structure
um and if you're reading like
documentation or blog posts this is also
referred to as a hidden class or a map
but it's kind of confusing because we
also have classes in javascript and we
have maps in javascript but it's not a
javascript class or a javascript map so
shape is the way to go because we don't
have those natively in javascript
so a shape is basically just the
structure of that object
and this shape contains pointers to the
offsets on which we can find the values
of the properties on the object because
even though we only specify the x y and
z properties there are many many more
built-in properties and objects
that also all have their location
somewhere stored in memory
so when we're trying to access a
property on the object for example x um
it can now just get it quicker by
checking okay does this object have the
same shape yeah it does okay cool uh now
i i want to get x so i know the offset
shapes are really useful for an
optimization technique that va uses
namely inline caching
with inline caching we basically store
the results from previous operations so
that the next time we call the exact
same operation we already know the
result now each time we do a property
lookup it can just simply store the
results for the offset that the last
time it didn't look up so in the future
when we're trying to perform the exact
same action it can simply just get the
result from the inline cache instead
now these inline caches are not only
beneficial for the interpreter but they
also generate really valuable feedback
for the turbofan optimizer so finally we
can go back to the bytecode example
because these values are actually
references to a feedback vector slot
where it stores information about the
execution of the function
and this includes information from like
arrhythmic operations such as the fact
that so far we've only added numbers
which result in a numeric value one
useful example of this is the fact that
in javascript you can also concatenate
strings with the plus operator which
would have to be handled way differently
internally but so far it knows okay i've
only had numerical values that's fine
now let's say that we're invoking the
calc function hundreds of times this
function is now considered hot um
because although the bytecode is already
really fast v8 actually uses turbofan
the turbofan optimizer in order to
generate machine code that's even faster
so based on the bytecode and the
generated feedback for specific code
blocks it can generate optimized
architecture specific machine code
that can run directly on your machine so
the next time that we invoke the
function it can just skip over the by
code and immediately execute the machine
code instead however there is one
problem in javascript namely that it's
dynamically typed so we can invoke the
calc function with the same object like
hundreds and thousands of times but
there is absolutely no guarantee that
this will always be the case in the
future for example we can also invoke
the calc function with an an empty
object
or just with an x key or just an x and y
key i don't know why you would do it but
it's possible so for all those different
types of objects va generates a new
shape that contains the new different
properties
so previously we saw that the inline
cache contained a field with a value of
the shape of the object and then the
corresponding offset however if we
passed multiple objects so multiple
shapes got generated we also have to
update the inline cache in order for it
to point to multiple shapes
and they're offset so now when we're
trying to load a property from a
specific object it first has to walk
through all the possible shapes in order
for it to find the object that contains
that specific property which could
result in a linear search which is not
very optimal but now previously we
generated machine code for the calc
function when it's only gotten invoked
with one type of object namely the
object with the x y and z keys
however if we call the calc function
again but with a different shape
turbofans
shape check fails in which case we can
no longer use this optimized machine
code and we actually have to de-optimize
back to the generated bytecode and this
is a pretty expensive operation that you
mostly want to avoid so the inline cache
of the calc function is also updated to
say like hey it's actually got multiple
shapes now
um now the calc function again can get
hot and optimized even after
de-optimization although turbofan has to
handle it a little bit differently when
it's encountered multiple shapes and
these inline caches actually also have
multiple states because if an inline
cache has only seen one type of object
it's considered monomorphic which is
pretty much the best case scenario
because in that case we can just
generate optimized machine code and
assume that in the future this function
will just get invoked with the same
object shape now if a cache has two or
four different shapes it's considered
polymorphic and if we're continuously
just invoking it with whatever random
types uh it's considered megamorphic in
which case it's like you know what never
mind i won't try to optimize it so as
you can see although it's pretty nice
for us sometimes as developers that
javascript is dynamically typed it's uh
it's not so great for the compiler and
it can really only work with
speculations and just assume that in the
future we will use the same type of data
now even though i had to walk through
this pretty quickly we went all the way
down from loading the script in our
browser all the way down to running
optimized machine code on your machine
and i just want to quickly mention that
there are so many great resources out
there um if you want to know more about
the internals of v8 and it's open source
so you can just check out the source
code if you want anyways thank you so
much for watching and have fun coding
wow love that oh man i love that we are
digging so deep into the internals of
javascript
so early in the day getting down to the
bite code
love it
love it all right but we should probably
keep these lightning talks rolling
yeah
yeah those visuals are fantastic
um got so many great talks for you today
this lydia halley's talk just now is so
awesome
and uh we are going to keep the fun
rolling with our next talk from
our next lightning talk speaker
swizz teller who is a software engineer
at tia i'm also a blogger at suzek.com
and creator of the serverless handbook
that you can find at
serverlesshandbook.dev
and so it's also created uh an open
source library called use off and i
believe we are going to be learning more
today about adding off to jam stack apps
and you can apparently add off to any
jamstack app in five minutes jonathan
does that sound possible
it is uh
just spoiler alert i've seen it and it
works it's incredible um
off is a hard problem this was going to
talk about why it's a hard problem um
and we're going to get into some some
details in a short talk which is really
cool we also hear that he's going to
make an exciting announcement today um
and i i really hope you all stick around
for that as well so let's get straight
into this talk with zach teller
hello everyone i'm swizz and today i
want to talk to you about a pesky little
topic called authentication it's one of
those things that you're going to need
to add to your react app whether you're
using create react app next js gatsby or
any of the other frameworks that you
like you are going to need to add
authentication at some point it sounds
pretty easy in theory right you need
some way of saving who the user is you
need to check with the server whether
they are the person they say they are
you need to potentially save their
password maybe their username and you
gotta do some little
you know it's pretty easy talk to the
server hey is this person logged in i
have these credentials
the server saves them and then things
kind of just work out that's how that's
how it usually works
but good authentication is where things
get really tricky because with good
authentication you have to deal with
things like security you have to deal
with authorization whether this person
even if you know that this person is
this person do they have access to this
page or do they have access to that page
are they an admin or the user are there
a meta admin whatever else you might
want to think of authorization is really
the hard part of a lot of authentication
where authentication is who are you
authorization is now that i know who you
are do you have access to a particular
topic or a particular resource that's
that gets tricky and then when it comes
to saving all of this stuff on the
server it gets even trickier because
well what if you're what if your
database gets licked leaked can people
read your passwords or can they not read
your passwords how is your hashing
structure are you still using hashing
from many many years ago or are you
using a modern salt and
encryption and whatever honestly it's
really hard to even keep up with what
you should be doing how you should be
doing it and then when it comes to
saving the authentication state on the
front end because the front end needs to
be like hey i know you're already logged
in and i know who you are so i need to
tell the server to check with the server
whether this is still true do you save
that in cookies do you save it in local
storage there's a lot of tricky little
things that come with that one of the
big ones is that once you split your app
into multiple apps you're going to want
to have an authentication service or
some sort of authentication provider
that can work with multiple services
like if i log in on ios
do i want to still be logged in in the
browser if i switch browsers do i still
want to be logged in usually as a user i
do but you as an app developer get into
a tricky situation where you have to
have api based authentication you can
just be passing cookies around because
you need to have you probably want to
use the same authentication for multiple
different clients whether they're a
server trying to do something in the
name of your user whether it's the web
app trying to do something in the name
of the web app all of that gets really
tricky so people start building
authentication services and they start
trying to think about how to do tokens
when you really get start reading about
it it kind of blows your mind i honestly
you just should never roll your own
authentication you should rely on a
service that already provides
authentication because there's a lot of
little tricky things that you get you
can get wrong and you don't want to end
up like equifax which leaked something
like many many 100 million users you
don't want to be the person who everyone
laughs at for oh wow they rolled their
own authentication lost everybody's data
and now you can just go to the dark
parts of the internet and get
everybody's social security numbers
because equifax had a breach
oops you don't want to roll your own
authentication you want to use somebody
who already exists who's out there and
whose
core business model it is to make it
easy for you to add authentication and
authorization and user management and
all that fun stuff to your app so you
have a lot of different options you have
off zero as one of them you have netlify
identity as a simple solution there's
aws cognito which is kind of tricky to
set up you have firebase authentication
and there's probably a bunch of others
you can build your own that follows the
same protocols but unless you have a
team of experts on authentication
authorization encryption jwt tokens and
really you have time to do this and it's
your core business model you should
probably just use somebody else once you
start using somebody's
authentication provider this stuff
still is kind of tricky to use um
especially on the jam stack or on the
browser you need to you have this weird
authentication flow where the user
clicks a button gets redirected to
somebody else's authentication page
and you want that page to be somebody
else's because that guarantees security
and make sure that you as the
application developer aren't sniffing
people's passwords and usernames which
you don't want to do
well you might want to do it but you
shouldn't want to do that so you
redirect them to a different page they
log in they authenticate and then that
page redirects them back to your page
and you have something called a callback
page which then processes the the
authentication looks at the looks at a
bunch of data in the
uh in the url sends it back to the api
for for your authentication provider
says hey is this data correct did you
send me this or is somebody trying to
hack this poor person and the
authentication provider says yes that is
okay and you have to then put it into
your global state you have to make sure
that every component that needs to check
hey is this person currently logged in
should they be seeing this authenticated
content should they be seeing this
authorized content and there's a lot of
little tricky things that you still have
to do
even though you're using somebody's
authentication provider and most of
these have to do with global state
management and making sure that you have
the right access and the right info and
you everywhere
so what i started building about a year
ago and has now just reached version one
yay use auth v1 is significant because
it now has support for multiple
authentication providers yay
also it's
there's been a lot of changes behind the
scenes so it's now easier to use and
configure and it just works better i
built this hook called use auth which
makes it really easy for you to add
authentication and authorization
anywhere in your react app it works with
nexjs it works with gatsby i've tried it
with create react app rather than have
you trust me at my word that this code
snippet is the best thing since sliced
bread when it comes to adding
authentication to your react app i'm
going to show you we're going to do
three minutes and we'll have
authentication added to a completely
blank gatsby app i started it with the
gatsby default starter i installed a
couple of dependencies and now we're
going to add authentication we're going
to start by
creating a config auth
react component that renders on every
page load
this part has also gotten a little
easier since i recorded this talk you
can see it in the documentation page
that's going to be linked at the end of
the talk if you're not familiar with
gatsby going into gatsby browser adding
a react a react component there helps
you add something to every page and
ensure that it's always rendering we
don't need to wrap it in anything
because
we're using x state behind the scenes so
there's no context provider or anything
like that that you need with use auth
everything is completely independent
we're going to take the dispatch
function from use use off this is a
helper that's returned from the use auth
that's returned from the user hook so
that you can send events to the x-state
machinery behind the scenes we don't
need to render anything because again
this is not a wrapper and we're going to
have an effect that runs or on every
initial page load but does not run on
subsequent re um re-renders we're going
to dispatch a set config event we're
going to give it an auth provider that
comes from
providers.net life identity we're going
to send use off our navigate function
this is so that it can work with any
routing solution that you want to use
you can always use use auth regardless
of what you're set up as long as you
give it the whatever function it needs
to call to navigate because it needs to
change between pages sometimes now to
show that it's actually working
we're going to go into index.js and
we're going to create a login
login component
which doesn't need to get any props it's
going to
take is authenticated
authenticated is a method that comes
from use off and tells us whether the
user is currently authenticated if the
user is authenticated
we're going to
return a logout button
button
which on click calls logout which comes
from use off
log out and we're going to say that we
are currently logging out
else
we're going to return a button
that on click
calls the login function
login
and we say
login so now a button should show up
here let's see if it does oh we need to
actually render it duh
so we're going to render the login
button here
we now get a button and when i click
this the netlify identity
should pop up and ask me
whether i want to log into this page
in theory that should work but it's not
five minutes later i don't know what i
did wrong because it now works without
me changing anything
computers right so i click login
and it asks me for the netlify url that
i'm using for your for netlify identity
i'm gonna copy it so that i don't type
or anything
and set site sites url i can now log in
as myself and i am logged in see the the
button changes to logout i'm still me if
i reload the page use auth looks at the
local storage and make sure that it
checks the when when my session is
expiring and preemptively puts me in the
logged in state before it talks to the
auth provider and verifies that that is
still true what i can also do here
is instead of just saying hi people i
can say hello to myself
so we're going to
return
this layout stuff and i'm going to
uh
user
equals use auth again everything
everything connects to the data in the
background without me having to really
think about it i'm just calling use aust
wherever i need something about being
being authenticated or about the current
user and if i'm authenticated i'm going
to show user.email
otherwise i'm going to say hello people
i need to get is authenticated
as well
let's see so it now says hi swizzads
blah blah blah i can log out
puts me back in log in and it just works
now let's say you want to change your
authentication provider you're tired of
netflix identity you want to use
something a little bit more powerful
with better administration features or
whatever what does it take
right now when you think about your
current app what does it take to switch
to a different authentication provider
it's usually a lot of work right so what
we're going to do now is switch this app
to using auth0 instead still using use
off and yes those are the only two
authentication providers that are
currently supported
it's this [ __ ] takes time so let's see
we're going to go back into gatsby
browser and instead of netlify identity
we're going to use alt0 as the provider
we're going to give it the dispatch
function and it's going to need a little
bit more configuration because we need
to set application keys and stuff like
that we're gonna have to create a new
all zero callback page as well this page
makes sure that all xero when it
redirects you back to your app has
somewhere to go we're gonna call it
all0callback.js
put it in source.pages and yes i'm copy
pasting from my old code because you
don't want to watch me type all of this
it's basically taking the handle
authentication function from use off and
calling it whenever that function
changes or the page is loading now let's
see
if this magically starts working five
minutes later giving you more power than
netlify identity but also a little bit
more responsibility click login
go to the auth xero authentication page
see this is fully secure it's on their
domain so i can't steal anything i'm
going to use my existing user it's going
to redirect us back yes i'm authorizing
the app to to be used comes back to the
callback page
and it should me should redirect me
immediately
but it is not so i'm going to switch to
the old mode because use auth v1 is
completely backwards
compatible with the previous stuff so
we're going to render this off provider
which the auth provider is designed to
magically set you up with aut00
so now this is reloading and it's
redirecting me back and yay it works so
obviously v1 still might have some bugs
by the time you watch this i will have
fixed them i can log out it redirects me
to the home page to make sure that
everything is fresh
log in
yes see it works as promised we got that
working in less than five minutes using
both of the providers that are currently
supported netlify identity and auth0
it's all use auth is designed so that
you can easily add different providers
i've created a an interface that is sort
that seems to be working for multiple
providers so i would like you because
this is open source you can add new
providers maybe add your own add your
favorite there's um i'm going to add
documentation on how to do that very
soon you can go to use auth.dev to learn
more about how all of this works to
learn more about how to provide how to
add different providers to read the
documentation and start using it in your
own app i'll be hanging out in the chat
room if you have any questions
off in five minutes
that's uh that is impressive on its own
it's so incredible um with this is like
the the problem that i hear about with
uh with these uh static
static site builders and that kind of
thing
uh so it's it's really cool and what's
even cooler is that we have swiss here
to talk with us uh and so i'm i'm
excited about that
welcome sweetie yeah
hey everyone hi
welcome we're so excited you could join
us for this live chat after that awesome
talk wonderful
um
we are we are really uh thankful to have
you here with us and especially now you
know we've heard so much about this um
this auth library we're gonna talk more
about it um in this chat right here but
for me i'm curious you know there are so
many things you've worked on so many
things that you do as a developer and as
an educator
what uh made you want to talk about this
topic here today with our audience
yeah so it's a funny story actually i
created the library itself it came out
of trying to teach people how to build
this stuff how to build full stack apps
and
by my second or third time i was like
this is stupid it's just always the
exact same thing this shouldn't be
something that you learn it should be
something that just works for you so i
created that library and i figured
it it's taken me a while but now that
it's v1 i wanted to talk about it at
react-a-thon and encourage people to
contribute and somebody asked in the
chat room about um
adding more providers you can add those
providers and i would really love it if
you did
so that's the official the official
request here is is for other people to
come along and
and bring their own providers because
now that it's in in uh 1.0 stage
uh it's ready for that right
yeah exactly the that was the big thing
that we that everyone's been waiting for
i've had a lot of people ask hey does it
support anything other than odd0 can i
use it with my own thing can i use it
with traditional sessions and
now you can i've only tested it with
netlify identity and
all zero but the idea is that there's a
an api layer built into the library that
lets you add more providers like almost
like a plugin system kind of there's an
abstraction layer and you if you follow
that abstraction layer you should be
able to magically make it work with
everyone but like i said in the talk
this [ __ ] takes time
yes and so important to get right
as we saw yes um absolutely so if folks
are you know wondering like oh man i
would really love to use this but it
doesn't have a plug-in for my uh
provider of choice provider that i'm
tied to they can actually go in and add
it themselves that's so exciting so
other than extending this to work with
more different auth services is there
anything else that you're hoping that
folks um you know come in and help out
with or things that you're thinking of
for v2 now that v1 is done
yeah i mean honestly
i just want people to use it try it out
tell me how it is
um
examples are always great i love it when
people like i originally built it with
just gatsby in mind and then somebody
came and added the create react app
example somebody added an xjs example so
i would love to see more of that because
i can't do everything myself and
examples in particular can be really
tricky to build but if anyone wants to
pitch in i would be super excited about
that
awesome enough i assume that oh go ahead
good job
here we are um so
i i assume the best place for people to
contribute would be
uh in the official repo
and where else can they find you and
your work
yeah so i'm super excited to push other
people's work as well i we have the all
contributors spec we follow it everyone
if you add code if you have
documentation you will be on the github
readme
as for my other stuff you can follow me
on at
swizzits on twitter if you put swizzits
into the internets in google you will
probably see the first three pages of
results are about me
i have serverlesshandbook.dev which is a
free resource if you want to get into
serverless and full stack stuff
and i blog at swisses.com i'm taking a
break right now but in general i post
relatively
often
awesome very thank you so much for
joining us
yeah thank you for having me
thanks again
oh man that's cool jonathan
we got we got so many cool speakers
yeah official official call for um
for people to go and create their own
auth providers that's that is one of the
hardest problems and that's that's so
exciting that that is uh that that's
getting better in the react
uh ecosphere i suppose ecosphere is that
a word
it is now it is now today you're here to
hear first folks the react ecosphere
coming at you live
and what i love about this is that um
you know i love uh venues like this
conferences you know in real life or
online where we can hear about these
exciting new libraries and tools that
are coming out that can make uh
developer life easier and folks can
actually go in and get involved in
things that they're excited about so
really hoping that some folks get to
connect with swiss after this on github
um that folks are able to use this
library successfully in their own work
and don't have to worry about off and
breaking it
so that is a super exciting
takeaway from this i think um but yeah
shall we keep it moving and keep on with
our our next amazing talk here
yeah absolutely let's go
let us go okay so our next talk is going
to come at us from alex krolick who is a
software engineer at box and a
maintainer of the react testing library
and that i believe is what we're going
to be talking about today
yeah you're going to learn how to use uh
async code in your react apps you're
going to learn how to use react testing
library to test that
uh this talk will show you how to test
async code such as network calls timers
and promises and react these are the
things of nightmares for a lot of
engineers especially when you go to try
to test them so you're going to learn
how to put those nightmares out of your
mind and sleep better at night hopefully
uh so let's get straight into this talk
with alex kralik
hello everybody and welcome to this talk
about testing async components i'm alex
scrollick i a good box and in my spare
time i help out with react testing
library
before we get into timers promises and
api calls i want to do a quick recap of
component testing 101
so what that looks like
is you'll have a ui element and you'll
go through three phases to arrange act
assert
steps
so in testing library terms
that's render the component then find
elements and fire events on them and
then use your expectations to do
assertions about the final state
so for this example we have a comment
box and we're going to pass in on submit
prop that's a just mock function um
into its
own submit handler then we're going to
find this uh element the text box
element we're going to enter a value
into it then we're going to click submit
and then finally we are going to move
into the
assertion phase and we're going to
assure that our
our click handler has been our submit
handler has been called with the right
data and that our text
submitted has appeared in the document
one thing you'll note
so we're not using act here because
react testing library wraps fire event
with that automatically so any effects
that are generated there
and microtasks are cleaned up by react
and rendered before we move on to the
next of the test
the difference between this component
and components in a real app is that
it's fully synchronous so there's no
delays everything happens immediately
whereas a real test is full of sources
of asynchronicity
from timers promises and networks
you're going to see animations browser
apis are going to be using promises and
everything is basically sync all the
time
so i'm going to walk through each of
those three elements timers promises and
network and talk about how you can deal
with
them so first
timers
i'm going to extend that previous
example a little bit and say that we've
debounced the change handler for the
input box that's inside of this comment
modal form thing
so
what a debounce does is it makes sure
that the function isn't called until the
user stops interacting with the thing so
we're now at a 200 millisecond delay to
prevent that change handler from being
called in every single key press that
will affect our test because we can no
longer immediately click that button
after we stop typing
because we're waiting for that delay to
kick in
so
what do we do about it strategy one we
just get rid of the timer completely so
we can find anywhere on our code that
has a timeout and replace that constant
with a zero
and the other thing that we can do is
mock out any functions that are creating
timers i.e the low dash
debounce function
and replace it with a mock function that
we can then assert about
so since blue dash debounce is fairly
well tested and we we kind of trust it
to work this is a pretty good candidate
for it because we can say was that
function debounced was that callback
debounced yes because of this this mock
but we don't care about the actual
implementation of that code running so
it doesn't affect our test anymore it's
no longer asynchronous
the other strategy that we can do is we
can use fake timers meaning it's like
driving a stick shift you're taking full
control of the test and all the time
inside of it so
uh the way that just handles it and
there's an equivalent sign-on is that
there's an api called fake timers
just use fake timer startsit
and every time you want to advance time
you have to call one of the apis it's
either run all timers which runs every
timer that has been created or advanced
timers by a time and that will
allow it to move forward just only by
that specific amount
so in our test after our change after
we're triggering that text box is change
event
we would advance the time by our
debounce
amount 100 milliseconds and then after
that we could finally click the putt the
disadvantage of this
is that if you have uh advanced timers
by time a round timer is all over the
place in your test it gets a little bit
hard to manage because um
now you have to know everywhere that a
potential asynchronicity is happening
and kind of manually work around it and
it can you kind of end up with manual
time and control all over the place if
this is something you use wildly
so
the alternative
and this is kind of the preferred
testing library pattern and something
that's very much enabled by testing
library apis is to make the whole test
async and then if you want to do uh any
optimizations around individual d-bounds
or anything like that you can but
anything small is going to be glossed
over
single ticks or 20 20
100 milliseconds
that'll that'll go off without hiccup in
the test so the big difference is
in how you write a test that's async
versus synchronous are these
so first
you've got to rewrite your test to await
syntax
so
by changing it to an async function you
can then use a weight anywhere which
kind of resembles a synchronous thing
but it's actually using promises under
the hood
and then the big difference is that
anywhere where you think that you may
have something that's going to take a
certain amount of time or certain amount
of ticks
you want to replace that manual weight
like you know wait 200 milliseconds or
advanced time or 20 milliseconds with an
assertion about the the next step um and
when it's ready to proceed
so in this case what we can say is that
that button is disabled well the input
box is empty once we type the value in
there it will become enabled
so what we can say is we can add this
little assertion inside of the wait for
callback that expects that button to not
be disabled and then after that becomes
true we'll be able to move on to
clicking it
so that's just a retrial assertion that
signals to us when we can continue the
test
if the assertion that we're talking
about is that an element is appearing we
have a shortcut which is that we can
replace any get by queries
with find by queries so we're replacing
our get by text with a find by text
which is an awaitable assertion that
will retry until that element is in the
dom
this pattern is basically what you're
going to use for promises as well as
most timers
it works pretty well in both scenarios
so if you have promises the first thing
you're going to do rewrite async tests
but the big difference between a timer
test and something that's dealing with
promises the promises typically affect
control flow
so the code needs to be testing both the
resolve path and the reject path
so
just mock functions can do that for you
so if i have a mock function like the
one we passed in on submit what we can
do is we can say mock rejected value
once that'll
say that when that function is called to
return a rejected promise with this data
which is a 500 status code a server side
error
and then we can have our async find by
text query that's looking for that
server error to be
shown to the user in the dom
now moving on our final source of
asynchronicity is the big one the actual
network
so
in a test you really don't want to be
hitting real servers because for one
they're unreliable um you don't want
your front-end test code to be totally
reliant on the entire backend system and
for a vital reasons you might not
actually be able to access it and then
of course as we've just shown there's a
good chance that we're also wanting
wanting to be able to test
you know error error paths or bad data
being passed in
finally of course it could be pretty
slow
so
the way we can deal with network api
calls in a unit test
um
first approach
take whatever interface that we're using
to call the api and mock it usually they
have a promise based interface so we
just use the same patterns that we've
been using
um so if we're using window fetch we
replace that with a mock function and
then we treat it like a regular promise
anywhere that we want to call
that api we replace the value
with some data that we've mocked out and
then we respond to the mock results
normally if we want to pass in bad data
we change it to a rejected downside of
this approach
if we change our mind about using window
fetch we change it to axios or something
um
now we kind of have to rewrite all of
our tests to conform to that new test uh
a new
data format so for example fetch you
always have to call res json do you want
to mock out you know the json methods on
all this stuff not necessarily um so it
might be kind of over constraining your
test a little bit if you're always using
these interfaces but to get started if
you just have a few calls that you need
to mock out this is definitely what you
can do it
a bit more sophisticated approach is
that we could actually mock out a fake
server so there's a few libraries that i
am aware of so mock service worker and
mirage js they both seem to work fairly
similarly the idea is that you have a
service worker that can intercept
calls to certain routes
and then replace them with fake
responses so in this example which i
pulled from the testing library docs um
we set up a server that is responding to
this greeting route and it's sending
back a bad
bad status code to 500.
so every time somebody calls slash
greeting
that's what they're going to get back
and then in different tests you can
change the response to something else um
this works pretty well the only real
downside here is that now we're kind of
couple to the network interface rather
than the specific library so potentially
if we're thinking about refactoring big
chunks of the app
we may want to have some kind of
abstraction between our actual network
calls and what we're doing in the app so
here's how you could do that
so
creating an api module is as simple as
creating a file let's call it api js and
then you put all of your code design
network in there so in this case we've
got something called get user that's an
async function takes an id and then it
does window fetch for a certain endpoint
if we later replace that with a
different library or we introduce
something
some response handling in there or even
rewrite it to hit a graphql endpoint
instead this will keep working because
the app code is insulated from that at
the same time the way that we use our
tests uh we use this module in our test
is we can generate create mock from
module which will take all of these
functions and replace them with mock
functions
and then we can say okay get user let's
change the
value to return say on authenticated
status code uh 401
or we could change it to return or
actual user data um
the downside with that again is that now
we kind of have created this additional
interface here so we do have to both
unit test it and validate that it
actually is correct um and then also if
you're working with state management
code that is very intelligent that makes
api calls on your behalf it's not
necessarily going to want to go through
this intermediary module so
um
so for these like very intelligent new
libraries that might not be the way to
go
so that said
we've been talking about just we've been
talking about unit tests i'm talking
about the downfalls where
interfaces can kind of not be quite
right between what we thought we were
testing and what actually happens when
we build the app so sometimes testing in
a real browser in an end-to-end testing
scenario is the way to go
cyprus is a pretty good library for that
cool thing about cyprus is that all of
its uh assertions all of its uh queries
for elements are already async so more
than the get queries they resemble the
find by queries in react testing library
um so the
built-in.get.contains methods
they're async
so they'll retry until that album exists
which is very good if you have
asynchronous code anywhere um
if you want to use the exact queries the
testing library exposes the role query
for example an accessible assertion or
an accessible query
or a label text or placeholder or
anything like that we have a plugin
called testing library cypress and you
can then use
all of those commands as well and they
behave in the exact same way
if you do decide that that intent test
maybe has a few paths that you weren't
able to test maybe you want to test
errors or something
you can do network mocking in cyprus 2.
so they've iterated through this api a
few times but where they've settled now
is called cypress intercept in older
versions it was called router route 2
but they are acting very similarly to
the service worker methodology that we
were talking about before where you say
an individual route
and then when it's called certain
arguments it returns certain values so
very powerful very useful
and ultimately
you have kind of a whole suite of
options available to you as far as
testing all the steps all this code
so that's pretty much everything i have
i'm hoping that
these techniques were useful to you if
you want to read more they're up to date
guys on the testinglibrary.com website
as well as react.js.org and justjs.io if
you want to get in touch with me my
website is alexcrolic.com and on github
i'm also alex frolick
thank you so much
a huge thank you to alex for joining us
and talking about
that asynchronous testing and cypress
and all of those good things
uh of course testing is always becoming
more important
as we build more and more complex
applications with react
they're they're about as complex as they
can get uh and um
hopefully you know the observability of
applications is a big deal right now and
that's kind of what we're gonna hear
about in the next talk right
on jenna
yeah so our next speaker is going to be
brian manuel who is a software engineer
at flexport and is going to be showing
us how to quantify
the health of a react code base which i
am really excited to learn about so
without further ado let's welcome our
next lightning talk speaker brian manuel
all right let's jump right in
so to kick off this presentation i want
to begin by telling you a story that
takes place in the year 1993.
now the year 1993 is a pivotal year in
computing history because it marks the
beginning of what is known as the
browser wars
now just three years prior
tim burns lee at cern had just invented
arbinet
uh thereby birthing would later be known
as the internet
and in this year the year 1993
we have uh the creation of three major
browsers the links browser the arena
browser and the mosaic browser
each find to become the first viable
user interface to world wide web each
bringing with them their own opinions on
what a browser should be
and how the markup language of the web
should be
and each
rapidly innovating eager to bring about
the new wave of the internet
links browser was the first scene it
brought with it the concept of html
followed by the arena browser which
brought the concept of the gui for the
web and also introduced the concept of
the image tag
and last but not least the mosaic
browser brought with a whole slew of new
tags such as form tag
nested lists etc
and also not so desirable tags such as
the blink tag and the marquee tags
and so 1993 was a period of dizzying
innovation in the browser sphere
all these browsers had uh wonderful
ideas on where the specs should go for
html
uh
and sometimes these ideas were at
conflict so in the year 1994 all the
major engineers and academics behind the
browsers decided to convene in geneva
for what was known as the w3c or the
world wide web consortium
and here's a picture that very first
meeting
and 3c essentially hashed out what the
spec for html and the web should be
and because of what w3c and what they
did
uh
we now have a standardized spec for html
javascript and css and we can pretty
much have a very consistent experience
across all the major browsers
and one thing that the introduction of
the w3c would introduce extra overhead
to the various browsers but it really
hasn't uh browsers are still innovating
at a rapid pace
here we have a picture of the web gpu
experiments that firefox is running on
firefox nightly
here's an image of html portal element
which is experiments that chrome is
running on chrome canary
and what w3 c brought to the table is
process invisibility into its innovation
cycle and so
you're able to track how web gpu is uh
progressing uh via their website
uh and how portal is progressing uh it's
very cool
and
the reason why i bring up the story
about
uh the browser wars and the forming of
the w3c
is because
it's a story about an ecosystem and
ecosystems share a very fundamental
concept called ecosystem life cycle
every ecosystem starts from some sort of
solid foundation
it will then go through a period of
rapid growth
and then
finally
consensus and best practices will emerge
in that ecosystem and
if
it it's so called for standards will
emerge as well
and it turns out that a react code base
is also an ecosystem and a subject of
this talk
us react code base will grow over time
and uh the team members that
write in that reaction code base will
grow over time and these team members
will introduce
new best practices new concepts new
packages entire new ways of thinking
into react code base
at some point we'll want to start
tracking
these ideas and how they evolve we want
to identify trends emerging best
practices and where we need to improve
just as the w3c did for the browser
sphere back in 1994
and once we understand these trends we
can begin to remote them and reinforce
them and if it's so called for answer to
standards
and guidelines
and so the person's talk is to get you
to a point where
you can be the w3c for your own react
code base
and
learn some strategies on how to manage
and guide the growth of your code base
and the process by which we'll be doing
so is this three step process we'll
first go over how you can ask
quantifiable questions about the health
of a react code base
how you can answer those questions using
stack analysis
and finally how you can crystallize
those best practices by turning your
analysis queries into
say lint rules or into code mods
and what we won't be going over so this
is react define after all and we will be
focusing prominently on react and
anything outside this cover react it
won't be covered so bottle stats code
styling ci cd
all these things are important but you
can get information on these elsewhere
and a little bit about me before we
begin
my name is brian uh my alias is for me
to rock sometimes just drock
and
i work on the front infra team at
flexport and i've been working here for
about the last two years
um why she listens to this talk is
flexport has one of the largest and
oldest react code bases
we adopted react five months after it
came out and we're pretty much react
monolith on the front end i also
contribute to react and react like
projects like doc gen
alright let's begin
so code base health
before we begin before we can begin at
quantifying anything
it's important that we ask ourselves
where a co-base is in its history and
also where it's going
what is the state of our code base today
when we think about these questions it's
important that we pose them in terms of
code based health
uh how stable how readable how
maintainable is our code base
and by asking these questions
we can begin to understand and get a
better feel for
what's working what isn't working
what needs improvement and how we can
improve those things that need
improvement
and so in this slide since this is
reactifon i have some examples of
questions that you can formulate around
the health and save your react code base
so let's just go over them
uh
our teams creating too many redundant
components
is our design system library over
generic or overly
or or not generic enough
our engineer is still using a legacy
approach to certain systems say css
styling and if so why
are we
uh achieving are we adhering to
accessibility standards
and
should this particular category of
component be generalized into a shared
component
so all these are questions subjective
questions that you can ask about your
react code base in the next slide we'll
go over an exercise on turning one of
these questions into
an injective question with objective
answers
so let's focus on one of those questions
is our design system library overly
generic or not generic enough
and to paint some context let's say
your company has an internal
design system team
and that team wants to understand the
adoption of their component to library
uh i always urge to probe deeper uh go
talk to that team figure out exactly
what they want and figure out metrics
based on your conversations with them so
let's say you go talk to that team and
you figure out that they're working on a
slew of form ui components
and they want to understand their
adoption rate
and what they need to do in order to
drive adoption
well now we have something to work with
we can formulate a question off that
what percentage of forms in our code
base used to form ui components from our
design system
and of the forms that don't let's just
list them that way the team can go talk
to those form code owners and figure out
what they need to do with drug adoption
and
that gives us some quantifiable data
that we can track
one the adoption rate of form ui
components
and two
uh a list of forms that are not using
form ui components
and
though these queries seem to be nebulous
it turns out that we can answer them
though very loosely with a stack
analysis
and the tools of choice i will be using
are ast explorer
and js code shift ast explorer is a tool
that will help us mock and test out our
stack analysis queries and js code shift
is a library that we'll be using for
actually writing these queries
all right so this is ast explorer ast
explorer is a tool we'll be using to
explore running stack analysis queries
with
it consists of four panels the top left
panel is some source code we'll be
testing against
uh here we have an example form called
my form which imports some form ui
components
renders some stuff and then it returns
the form
on the right hand side we have a
tree representation of our source code
so if i were to for instance highlight
this import decoration on the left-hand
panel it highlights
the stringful import decoration
uh if i were to highlight this block
statement it highlights block statement
to the forum
it's essentially a true representation
of our source code
and then on the bottom left hand corner
we have our transformer so transformer
for js code shift
takes some source code and outputs
resulting source code
so
here uh it's parsing our source code
looking for any identifier and then
reversing uh the text of that identifier
and you can see that in the output on
the bottom right panel
all the identifiers are reversed for the
sake of this presentation we're not
interested in a transformation so
we can delete this and it'll default
it's just returning our source code as
is
going back to our formulated question
statement what percentage of forms used
to form ui components we can now break
this question down into two distinct
steps
step one
get a list of the form components in our
code base and in step two from that list
determine which forms contain any form
ui components
and the way we'll be doing so is by
looking at the opponent's import
statements
so for step one it turns out for a
theoretical codebase that we're working
on
doing this is pretty simple
all forms have the convention of ending
in form.jsx so we can simply walk
through a project directory and match
for any component file that matches that
regex
for step two in order to determine
whether a form contains formula
components we'll do what i described
earlier check the forms import
statements
and the way we'll be doing so is via js
code shift
um so the first thing i'm going to do is
i'm going to copy over this list of form
ui component import paths
into this file this is a list of all the
known form ui components in the report
paths
and our strategy is going to be
uh first
find
all the import declarations
in this file
and then uh check if any reference
the above
import paths
and so it turns out with js code shift
this is actually quite straightforward
we simply call tree.find
jscodeshift.import declaration
and uh
we care about this uh import path so we
call.find again
uh this import path is a literal so we
call find.literal
and if we
run for each
on each of these literals
and console.log each of them
or rather their value
let's open up our console we can see
that we are indeed hitting these uh
import paths
this is what a full implementation ends
up looking like
now for those of you who want to read
this code and dig in
don't you worry at the end of this
presentation there is going to be a link
to github just with the full
implementation that you can read play
around with and do a fashion please
so i hope this section gave you a quick
taste of what it's like to write a stack
analysis query i hope it didn't go by
too fast
the final section crystallizing best
practices
i'm going to show you a scenario say
your company is doubling down on
internationalization and
through analysis we found that we really
like i18n
we don't want to have any
free-floating texted rules in our jsx
everything must be passed through i18n
for internationalization
and our company wants us to enforce this
as a standard
so there are two ways we could go about
this um
the first way is we can introduce an
eslint rule
here we've introduced a new rule called
no string literals and it'll create a
violation whenever it finds a string
literal uh free floating in your jsx
this is extra work for your engineers
because it means that they'll need to
dig into the code and remove these
violations and fix them themselves
and the other approach is we can write a
code mod now the query we wrote
was in js code shift and the purpose of
js code shift is for writing code mods
uh and what codebond is is essentially a
transformation of code you go from one
type of code to another type of code and
here we transformed all these free
flowing text rules to be passed through
i18n
now using uh codemod isn't always
possible uh there might for instance
there might be too many edge cases or a
lot of
complexity uh but uh in general you
should always hear writing code mod and
if you can't
definitely go for an eslint rule
um
so yeah those are two ideas on how you
can
crystallize best practices
and that's it for my presentation
reach out if you have any questions i'm
going to be at the topic tables later
today uh so you can talk to me there uh
or reach out earlier it doesn't matter
and as promised there are links to the
code samples um that's all
have a great reaction find everybody and
thank you for listening to my talk
awesome
react uh quantifying react code base is
difficult uh but
luckily brian has made that seem much
easier much easier for us
now we are going to move into a very fun
part of the day um as a special part of
this conference which is our live topic
tables this is where you
can get up up close and personal with
the speakers uh the workshop instructors
sponsors and other experts on a specific
subject
just click on the sessions button
if you don't know where that is it's in
hop in on the left side of the screen
the sessions buttons in the left menu to
browse all of those topic tables you
could talk about the jam stack with
guillermo for example uh you could uh go
talk about going from junior to senior
engineer with swix
or
next js with joe
uh you can talk about data
visualizations with janet beck and many
more talks will start up back in a
little over an hour at 1 30 pacific time
we'll be back here
talks will start up back then so we'll
see you back here shortly thanks for
joining us
i've had my heart broken
into
but something's different next to you
it's like my soul is
i'm starting to feel tired
cause i can
is
i know
feelings that i know
i can't keep on this road alone
and all this time i
thought all this time
bottled up inside
is
is
feelings
to feel
is
wanna know is are you ready for the ride
what have i been waiting for oh i can
run but i can't hide the feelings that i
know
next
so
without you baby
is
tell me
i'm
baby
is
is
nobody
is
tell me
is
give me
me baby
there's a song in my head
so i love you so bad
every single crowd
and i know you love me
is an open sky full of dreams
till the sky
falls down
since i met you i didn't know
is
so pick me
i think you're perfect
for me
[ __ ]
it's
i was watching you
show me something
singing
through the windows
like superheroes
i couldn't see it
until you showed me
is
through the windows
every night on fire
tonight is
i've had my heart broken into it
but something's different next to you
it's like my soul
cause i
is
that i know
the feelings
feelings that i know
the feelings that i know
i can't keep on this road alone
and all this time i thought
up inside
is
feelings that i've known
is
is
is
bottled up inside
and all
the feelings that i know
next
living in the light you're giving out
without you
tell me
never gonna let you down
baby
home here in your eyes
without your baby
is
nobody
is
tell me
is
tell me
is
baby
me
when you're with me and i realize what
it all means
so i love you so bad
every single crowd
and i know you love me
is sky full of dreams
oh
till the sky
i was doing just
when the lights
is gonna
so pick me
every day i'm with you i think
[ __ ]
i was watching
show me something new as each morning
underneath
is
still
singing
is
this is
come with us
don't
hold back tonight is
is
is
it's
is
so
i've had my heart broken into it
but something's different next to you
it's like my soul is
know is
the feelings
the feelings that i know
the feelings
i can't keep on this road alone
and all this time i thought i knew
up inside
is
that i've known
feelings
this
that i know i can't keep bottled up
inside
is are you ready for the ride
what have i been waiting for oh i can
run but i can't
the feelings that i know
next
so
space
tell me
never gonna let you down
baby
without you baby
is
nobody
all this is
welcome back everybody
i will give give folks a few seconds
here to
get back in and settled
uh for our next talk this is we're going
back to a a bit of a longer talk here
with jana beck
janet beck is a data visualization
engineer at stitch fix in previous life
she was a phd candidate in linguistics
doing a lot of scientific computing
in python now you may be wondering okay
we're doing uh data visualization
engineering with react
uh this this could be a
uh a difficult thing to do in the
browser and that's exactly what janna's
gonna be talking about how to actually
do data science in the browser how to
perform
those kinds of tasks that are typically
reserved for cloud computing
so let's get straight into the talk with
jana hello reactathon and welcome to
escaping flatland a romance of data
science in the browser
now this title is a reference to a
mathematical fable that we'll get to in
a bit and we will torture the heck out
of as a metaphor in this talk
but
first let me introduce myself my name is
jana beck i'm a data visualization
engineer at stitch fix which is a
company based in san francisco
california
we are an online
retailer we offer personal styling so
for women men and children so you sign
up you fill out a style profile you can
also play a game we have called style
shuffle to tell us about
your style preferences and a sort of
tinder for clothes kind of way
um and
and then we match you with a stylist who
picks out things and sends them to you
you don't pay upfront for all the things
that are getting sent you just try them
on and pay for what you decide to keep
and ship the rest back
and then in the last year we also
launched a sort of personal store type
of service where you just log in and
we will show you a selection of all of
the things that we think based on what
we know about your style will be the
most interesting to you and then you can
just shop at your own convenience item
by item
now i work on
the algo ui team
which is a sub team of the data platform
engineering team that supports about 120
data scientists in our algorithms
department or data science department at
citrix
and this is a pretty unusual role for
front-end engineering
but it's pretty fun so we basically
operate as internal consultants we float
around
from project to project partnering with
one or more of the data scientists on
the team
to surface their work in whatever way is
necessary but usually through a web
application of course
to their business partners in the
company so it's it's internal tools um
or tools might be the wrong word
sometimes it's things like prototyping a
algorithmically driven experience like
something that might even be client
facing one day
sometimes it is just putting together
dashboards of business metrics or
operational metrics uh that business
partners throughout the company need to
see
so it varies a lot we create a lot of
new applications all the time
which is pretty interesting and a little
different for the typical front-end
engineering job
so coming back here to the subtitle of
this talk a romance of data science in
the browser we're not going to talk
about doing all types of data science in
the browser though you can do a
surprisingly large amount with something
like tensorflow.js which is an
implementation of the tensorflow
framework in javascript
what we're going to do in this talk
instead is focus on one particular
technique that's very useful for
visualizing certain types of data sets
that occur in data science data sets
that we call high dimensional data sets
so
this technique is called dimensionality
reduction
now what is dimensionality reduction
there are quite a few examples that are
actually probably pretty familiar to you
so one is maps
maps are
a way of reducing the three-dimensional
globe to two dimensions so that you can
print it out or display it on a screen
and there's lots of different map
projection algorithms and they're all
very specific to
the earth and and
making the earth
from two dimens three dimensions to two
right so you have the much maligned
mercator projection you have
newly developed projections that are
much better than the mercator projection
like the equal earth projection and you
have exotic projections like this one
the watermen's butterfly projection and
these are all of course extremely
specific but there are more generic
algorithms for doing dimensionality
reduction on any data set and indeed on
data sets that have hundreds or
thousands of dimensions
work we're going to look at in this talk
is doing
one particular dimensionality reduction
algorithm that's pretty newly developed
this is pretty cutting edge
and doing this in the browser so this
algorithm is called umap and that's an
acronym for uniform manifold
approximation and projection but we're
not really going to get into what that
means because that's not actually
relevant here
okay so let's dive into umap and see it
in action and we'll start with something
that should be pretty familiar to you as
front-end engineers and that's color
spaces
so
the rgb color space has three dimensions
red green and blue
and so as i'm sure you probably know you
define
millions of colors by encoding three
different numbers from zero to 255
for each of those channels those red
green and blue channels so we can
visualize this in the proper three
dimensions for those
three channels
by uniformly sampling from
the allowed values 0 to 255 for each and
we get this uniform cube
and then we can actually just apply umap
to this telling it to map it onto two
dimensions and it will get flattened out
just like this and you can still sort of
see some features of
the original
geometry here in in that you see these
like corners it's pretty interesting and
you'll get a different result
if you do the same thing on the hsl
color space visualized here in its three
dimensions but it's not a cube it's a
cylinder because the hue dimension in
hsl is an angle from a circle the the
hue circle
so if we flatten this one out we get a
very different result and again this is
just applying umap from three dimensions
to two and and again you kind of see
some of those features of the original
geometry you get these curves here with
the hsl
where you didn't see those with the
rgb
so now that we've looked at something
pretty familiar color spaces let's look
at something that's more
data science-y and that's the mnist
digits data set so this is a data set
that has as we'll see a hundred
dimensions so much more high dimensional
than three
and it's commonly used to test a variety
of machine learning techniques
so what this data set is is a set of
images
of hand drawn digits and each image
is reduced to being 10 pixels by 10
pixels so there's basically a grid
of 100 squares and
each square is one dimension
and what all we're encoding here is
whether that square that pixel and the
100 pixels
how filled in it is with black versus
white
so here's an example of one of the
hand-drawn digits a number eight and
here's the
grid of 100 squares and so if we look at
a particular location like 2 2 here
this one has a value of 0 because it's
all white whereas 3 2 has a value of
perhaps 0.825 because it is mostly black
so if we apply an algorithm like umap a
dimensional dimensionality reduction
algorithm to a data set like the mnist
digits data set that has 100 dimensions
what we expect to see is clustering of
the hand-drawn digits together by digit
value because
what the uh
algorithm is doing is comparing each of
those like dimensions so comparing pixel
0 0
across all of the 5 000 examples that
we're going to give it here uh the 5 000
hand drawn digits and then it will
categor it will put all the similar ones
the ones that are similar across all
those 100 dimensions
it will show us that by clustering them
on the two dimensions of our screen
so
if we look at the result that's exactly
what you see here applying umap to 5000
of the mnist digits
and what's interesting and
uh what actually makes umap a better
dimensionality reduction than some that
are similar is that you also get
similar shapes
appearing the the cluster for each digit
and for each shape
um
the relationship between those clusters
is also relevant which sometimes it
isn't with other dimensionality
reduction techniques so for example the
fours and the nines are right next to
each other which you can see because
they're very similar shapes um
just differ basically and the a9 is like
curved on the top whereas the closed
portion of a four
is has sharp angles on the top um so
those are very similar and they appear
right next to each other
similarly down um the red ones here are
threes and the sort of citrine color is
is eights and those are also very
similar of course you just three is
basically an eight with a couple bits
erased from it right
so that's one of the advantages of umap
that you can see very clearly in this
example
so i told you before that escaping
flatland was a reference to a
mathematical fable and that fable was
the book flatland a romance of many
dimensions written by edwin abbott
abbott and first published in 1884.
now this mathematical fable a romance of
many dimensions
uh is the story of its pseudonymous
author a square a square is
a square as you might imagine who
occupies flatland a two-dimensional
world
this land is also populated by other
polygons and lines but
all the beings that occupy this world
are two-dimensional
now the climax of the story spoiler
alert
is when one day flatland is visited by a
being from
spaceland which is a three-dimensional
world and a square witnesses this
visitation
now how does a square know
that
this being is from another
uh
world with a greater number of
dimensions well basically because the
sphere is able to apparently teleport
because he's able to move into the third
dimension
and then intersect flatland in a
different location
seemingly by magic
so here's the part where we torture
flatland as a metaphor and we're going
to use it as a metaphor for the web
browser itself
now the web browser started out as
something pretty simple and not very
powerful it was a way to view
hyperlinked text documents nothing more
images came later video came later
things like webgl came way later
but today the web browser is pretty
powerful as i mentioned before
tensorflow has been implemented in
javascript as tensorflow.js
we'll be working with the javascript
implementation of the umap algorithm
that i introduced you to briefly
um in a library called umapjs
and
these are computationally expensive
things almost by definition
and if you just implement them in the
main thread the main execution context
in the web browser you're going to cause
jank you're going to freeze the ui it's
not going to be a happy experience for
the user
but
what
the browser has today is the ability to
accept visitors from space land from
a larger more dimensional world a world
that has concurrency basically is not
limited to
one single thread of javascript
and that technology that we have today
is the web worker
so let's talk about web workers if
you're not familiar with them
so the the worker context is very
similar to the main javascript execution
context in every browser but there's a
few differences so just like in a in a
regular
main thread context you can make xhr
requests to get data asynchronous
asynchronously
but you do not have access to dom or
even a dom and you don't have a window
global instead you have a self global
all data transfer between a worker and
the main thread is done by message
passing
and this data is not is copied with one
exception that we'll go to later um and
instead of being shared across the
worker and the main thread
and it's serialized and then
deserialized via the structured cloning
algorithm so what are all the things
that are serializable by structured
cloning
well it's basically a whole host of
things that you'd expect all the
primitive data types of javascript dates
blobs array buffers
but some things that it would be useful
to pass back and forth that you cannot
pass back and forth cannot serialize by
a structured cloning
are things like dom nodes error objects
and functions
the
basic web worker code would look
something like this it's just a big on
message handler that receives data from
the main thread
and then you can do anything you want
probably something computationally
expensive
and then there's a global post message
handler that you just use to pass the
result back whenever it's done
on the app side you instantiate a web
worker with the new keyword and then you
call the
uh uh the postmessage method on that
instance that you've just created to
pass your initial data to the worker or
any message at all of course you could
have a more complex system of message
passing where you have types for all
your messages and they do different
things
and then you have a you just define an
onmessage handler to receive the results
whenever the worker is done
as far as tool chains the support for
webworkers is quite good in my
experience so the worker loader from
webpack is what i've used for many years
you can just tell it that any file
ending in worker.js should use this
worker loader and it bundles it up
appropriately i've also heard great
things about the worker eyes loader
which you
can be used on any you know file that's
just a single function and you don't
even have to write the sort of webworker
message passing boilerplate it will just
as it says workerize that function and
make it into a web worker
parcel i haven't used personally but i
found a codepen example that used uh
parcel to bundle up a
uh webworker so i think that works uh
the only thing that i haven't had great
success with is roll up um if you're
building a a library and you want to
have a worker that people can use
um
roll up uh the plugin i tried a few
years ago didn't work for me i do think
there is a new plug-in out in the last
year or so so that may
work now but it didn't before in my
experience
so let's dive into some demos and these
demos are going to be on a thousand of
those mnist digits that we saw before
running umap to
cluster them by similarity by digit
and the first demo is going to be the
one where we run umap in a webworker and
you will see a couple other things on
the screen there'll be a frame rate
meter in the upper left and
a keyboard input that i'll be typing in
in the upper right and so with the
computation happening in the worker
you'll see that my keyboard
input is active the entire time while
the computation is running or active in
the sense that the ui will be updated my
input is being accepted immediately as
we hope and expect there's no lag no
jank
so let's give that a try and see how it
goes so we'll just start it up here
and there you can see 216 frames per
second
very responsive and that keyboard input
was updating the entire time because
that computation was happening off the
main thread and not
interfering with the main ui at all
now in contrast same initial conditions
a thousand imnis digits but we're going
to run this umap in the main thread and
try to do the same thing
look at the frame rate and
watch the
lag and drank on the keyboard input
so here i'm typing away as i'm sure you
can hear
but
don't see anything from the keyboard
until it finishes at two frames per
second because it couldn't even update
uh while it was computing
sadly that's what happens in the main
thread
okay so for a third demo here this is
basically just the same as the first
we're going to do the umap in the worker
for performance
but bump up the number of digits to 2500
and you'll see that we do start to see
performance implications even with the
worker implementation here
so the final frame rate there was 86
frames per second quite a bit
slower than before
and now for a fourth demo which i'll
just leave my face off for this one
because it takes a little bit longer
um we'll just bump up the end to 5000
and
see how that goes
so here you see that there was an
initial period of time when the keyboard
input wasn't updating on the screen but
then it's kind of like all the others
just again with a lower frame rate we're
in the 40s now four frames per second
okay so there's a little bit more that
we can do in a web worker to optimize
performance and we're going to talk
about two more things basically
transferable objects and then
one type of transferable object or one
specific
instance of that which is an off-screen
canvas
so transferable objects are the
exception to what i said before about
data passing between the main thread and
a web worker being exclusively a copying
operation transferable objects are zero
copy they are basically the
conceptual equivalent to path by
reference in other programming languages
so here's an example of
using transferable objects to pass the
result of a umap computation back
without having to copy it so it's a
little bit faster so here i'm just
taking the result the embedding which is
what you call it when you reduce a high
dimensional data set
just taking that embedding and storing
it in a float32 array and then in the
post message there's a second argument
which is an array
and you put everything in this array
that is a transferable object or is of
an appropriate type that can be a
transferable object and that just tells
the the worker to not copy it and treat
it differently and pass it to the main
thread instead of copying it to the main
thread
so then the second
transferable object or specific type of
transferable object that's not an array
buffer is an off-screen canvas and this
is
a weird thing and it's not transferable
objects in general the array buffers
those are supported in every browser but
this is something special and new and
only a couple browsers have it so far
um it's basically like a canvas element
that is
a non-dom version of the canvas element
um
so here's an example of some some code
of how you would actually use this you
you know you want to
you just you do render a canvas element
in your dom like normal so here we've
rendered one that has the id off screen
and instantiate a render worker we'll
call it because we're going to render
onto this canvas and the word her
then grab a reference to that canvas
element that's been rendered and call
this method transfer control to
off-screen
then you also have to post a message to
the worker and include in the body of
the message that you're passing
this reference to the canvas and then
also include that that reference to the
canvas in that array of transferable
objects that's the second argument to
your post message
then in the worker code remember a
worker is basically just a big on
message handler you pull that canvas out
from the message and
and then you just render onto it using
the canvas api or the webgl api
how you would normally render onto any
kind of canvas and here you don't even
have to pass it back like the worker
rendering onto this canvas is
just this it's kind of like a
multi-dimensional wormhole back to the
browser it just appears that rendering
just appears in the browser where that
canvas element was rendered so this is
total magic in my opinion it's very cool
okay so now we're approaching our final
demo here where we're going to have the
main thread and two workers one to do
the umap computation and one just to do
the rendering of each iteration of this
algorithm as it converges on the result
so the conditions here are the same as
the fourth demo that we saw with 5000 of
the mnist digits
and now you can see with the comparison
of the embedded one in the upper right
corner that
this one has gotten responsive a lot
faster than that last one
and the reason also that there's no
framework meter on this one is because
all the frame rate tools
are not compatible yet with off-screen
canvas so i couldn't actually put that
in this final demo
so to conclude in my opinion the
combination of web workers especially
with off-screen canvas
gives you something that is basically an
escape from the flatland of the browser
because you can just do
much more computationally intensive and
exciting things
and if you have any questions i'm happy
to answer them on twitter where i'm i
pancreas i'm jebec on github and also in
various slacks or discords that's
usually the name i'm under
and you can also look at these slides
again online if you want all the
demos are live embedded in the slides so
you can just play with them if you feel
like it at janetbeck.com
flatland
and then if you also take a look at
these slides you can go through these
details of what i use to put together
the demos and this whole slide deck in
general if you're curious about that
thank you so much for your time
so we can do
machine learning in the browser or maybe
not machine learning but uh these these
pretty interesting kind of intensive
uh computationally intensive things in
the browser
off of the main thread that's really
cool thank you jana for
the fantastic talk and obviously the
kind of stunning visual display that we
saw there that was cool
yeah how amazing i also love that jenna
has this uh prior background in
linguistics because that's also the
background that i come from so love
seeing folks uh go from uh studying
things like dimensionality reduction in
the language world and bringing that
into uh computing and data vis and
whatnot super cool thanks so much
jennifer that awesome talk
and now we've got another an amazing
talk for you to to round out our day um
our next speaker i feel like perhaps
needs some introduction uh sean
swix-wang uh who you may know as an
infinite builder
is uh formerly of netlify and now
developer advocate at aws who works on
developer experience and developer
developer communities and is also
just an amazing speaker writer teacher
who i've had the pleasure of running
into a various conferences myself and
today uh swix is going to be talking to
us about
typesafe full stack react
and we're going to
be live coding an apt with react and
typescript and graphql to demonstrate
during his talk so wow
get ready for some fun with uh full
stack type safety in this next talk by
swix
hello reactathon i'm really excited to
be joining you today i hope all of you
are safe and at home and today we're
going to talk a little bit about
typesafe full stack react it's a broad
introduction for those people who
haven't considered it and a live demo
for people who have and hopefully you
might learn a new thing or two so let's
get started so for those of you who
don't know me
hi i'm sean i am sitting here in
singapore but i could be anywhere as far
as you're concerned and i also go by
swix on the internet that's my english
and chinese initials i've had the
privilege of giving some well-received
reactive talks in the past in 2018 i
kicked off my react conference speaking
career with why react is not reactive at
react rally 2018
and then in 2019 i followed it up by
giving my talk on hooks and cloning
uh react clone from scratch in 29 lines
of code live on stage and that was
pretty much the scariest and best
received talk that i've done
in 2020 i also
extended that to concurrent react so
giving an explanation and live code demo
of react fiber as well as the
implications of that with time slicing
and react suspense but more recently my
interests have turned from react
internals towards everything around
react the tooling and the developer
communities around react and that's what
we're here to talk about today the
stunning evolution and adoption of
typescript within the react ecosystem
and why is type safety so important to
react well i can pretty much make that
argument in two words and that's
shifting left
shifting left is this concept that's
kind of new to web development or
obscure in web development but it's not
new to software engineering in general
so if you look at ibm who did a survey
of their hundreds of thousands of
consultants and consulting projects
they discovered that there's a
correlation between how late in the
process of the software development
cycle where they catch a bug
versus how much it takes to actually fix
that
and it's also non-linear so if you
arrange the software process from design
to implementation to testing to
maintaining a production application
from left to right the further right it
shifts towards something that's already
shipped then the more expensive it is to
fix that bug so a bug in production is
like 100 times more expensive than if it
was caught at the design stage i like
this quote that people have that you can
save weeks and weeks of coding with just
hours of planning and i think that
that's a really true statement
even more than that you can automate a
lot of that planning and checking with
type systems
so the way i pitch this is it's not just
type systems it's also about building
automated developer tools so let's
translate this shift left concept into
terminology that we understand because
we're not ibm
so instead of relying on user bug
reports and manual qa we can actually
run tests inside of ci cd setup
environments
but instead of running that entire test
suite we can actually just run tests on
incremental commit hooks and diffs
so it's even faster
so what else can we do that increases
the feedback loop even faster than that
we can shift left again and we can run
formatting on save that's what prettier
is about and that actually
unlocks another order of magnitude
improvement in our software development
cycle but what can we do that shifts
even further left than that well while
we read our code our ides can actually
tell us if we've written code that's
wrong so that's what the typescript
language server and syntax highlighting
and ides do for us they tell us when
code looks wrong while we're writing
that code we don't even have to save we
don't have to commit we don't have to
build or run it we can just look at it
while we write and that is the highest
possible
version of shifting left in terms of our
error detection everything that we're
doing here
is to try to reduce the length of time
it takes to discover code errors and it
should directly translate to dollars
spent as well
the shift left idea also trickles down
in terms of other features that are also
nice fearless refactoring is this
concept i really like which says that
the only way to avoid techdab is to not
be afraid of refactoring your code base
at any point and the only way to not be
afraid of refactoring your code bases at
any point is if your developer tools
help you refactor so i can refactor any
part of my code base and if anything was
forgotten or if i broke any code i don't
have to run the code again the ide would
mostly just tell me what i need to fix
typescript and type safety also helps
you generate autocomplete because that's
another implication of type checking
it's kind of the inverse typescript also
helps you inline documentation so you
don't have to remember what exactly each
name means you can just hover over
variables and functions that it tells
you what it does in terms of type
signatures or type annotations but i do
want you to know that types do not
replace tests i actually wrote a post on
css tricks on why types and tests serve
overlapping but different purposes and i
encourage you to check that out i'm
personally quite tired of this
discussion because i think it's a solve
issue that you should have both my
ultimate sales pitch to you on why type
safety
is that you can go from moving fast and
breaking things to move fast without
breaking things and that's ultimately
what we all want right okay so let's
talk about typesafe front ends i've
helped to maintain the react and
typescript cheat sheets for over two
years and i've learned a lot about this
so normally i just give a screenshot of
what this basic component looks like but
because this is pre-recorded video i can
go one step better and actually show you
inside of a typescript playground so
here i have a basic function component
and it's being used inside of an app
this looks exactly like javascript
because it is and that actually shows
you one of the benefits of typescript
which is that it is a superset of
javascript any valid javascript is valid
typescript under the right settings
obviously you can make it a little bit
more strict and that's a little bit of
what we're going to do so here we're
going to turn on the no implicit any
check and that's going to start causing
errors so it's going to start telling us
that props implicitly has an any type so
we need to give
the type and specify the type of the
component so let's go ahead and say that
my type of component
is going to have an id and the id is
going to be a
string
so let's put that in there
and this is going to type check properly
properly so when i hover over props.id
it's going to tell me that is a string
okay so that's a simple reactant
typescript app
but what if we wanted to do a refactor
that's exactly what we're trying to go
for right so let's say i wanted to
change my id
into a number
so if i change that number here it's
going to light up accordingly so for
example here i wanted to say
i i'm running around a specific
number
function like two exponential
i don't know what this is so it's going
to document what i need to put in there
so it must be in the range 0 to 20.
excellent okay i can just say 15.
i don't really care what it is but now
i can just
see that this code type checks because
this the this returns the appropriate
value but also i can see that here
i have
another place in my app that i need to
fix as well so i need to change this
instead of supplying a string into a
number so that's a very simple
demonstration of what the refactoring
workflow looks like
and what designing with types helps you
consider when you're doing
development with react and typescript
typescript types are basically
instructions to the typescript language
server in compiler that says
you know id is of a certain type so
let's try something a little bit more
complicated
with our stateful component we're
annotating both props and state
and i'm doing it both in terms of the
class component style as well as the
function component styles using hooks
you can see how hooks are a lot more
concise to type with typescript that was
not a motivation but it was definitely a
nice to have and a plus in favor of
adopting hooks the classes versus hooks
discussion is also something i'm not
very interested in discussing so
leave
your flame wars in the comments but in
general what applies for props also
applies for state if you try to refactor
anything in a state then the rest of
your app is going to update accordingly
and that's a very useful thing to have
in your reactor
so that's a super brief introduction
there's a lot more for example when
you're making custom hooks here i have a
custom used loading hook which covers a
used state hook
but then also has some custom behavior
going on this hook just helps to wrap
any promise so that it tracks the
loading state
and then unsets the loading state once
the promise completes and it returns
that loading state as a boolean and it
gives you a function which you can call
to use generically the trick here is
that you cannot just return is loading
and load in an array like you would in
regular javascript because
typescript would infer this weird
type that is very hard to use and union
type of both boolean and load
instead you actually need to specify
this special as const syntax of
typescript and that actually tells
typescript to infer as a tuple so
in each place instead of assuming that
i'll have a general type that matches
each of the locations in the array
and here is where we use it in a app as
a sample where i can wrap any promise
and get out that loading state which i
can use to show a loading indicator
there's a bunch of these little tricks
that you need in typescript in order to
do these things so it's not exactly
clean there is a learning curve but
hopefully it's worth it and you know
what most of the ecosystem has decided
that it's worth it so here i have a
tracker of
the react ecosystem libraries that are
either written in typescript or have
rewritten their code types here so they
don't just offer typescript types or
indefinitely typed or like a separate
type to file their internals are written
in typescript and so that's next.js
react native react router expo redux
yarn jest and so on gatsby i think now
fully supports typescript as of
november 2020.
the other thing that's very gratifying
is that it starts to bleed over from
open source into closed source
large-scale production systems one of
the most compelling stories comes from
rebunge at airbnb where she drove the
adoption of typescript at airbnb and
according to their own study because
they keep very rigorous postmortems
38 of airbnb bugs were preventable with
typescript it's also a very compelling
story for those who think that you don't
need typescript if you test enough
because of course airbnb also tests very
very rigorously
if you were around tech twitter last
year when this became a story and it was
announced then you probably saw this
version of this photo and it spread
pretty virally around javascript twitter
the reason was this talk wasn't publicly
streamed and i just happened to be in a
room so i'm happy to have my little
contribution to reaction typescript lore
if you want to get started learning then
definitely check out my repo it's
completely free it's called react and
typescript cheatsheet there's a github
version where you can just read in pure
markdown but there's also a hosted
version with search i definitely like
using the search feature for anything i
need to look up
we definitely need contributors so
please dig through the issues and ask
questions or answer them as they come up
okay so that's the front end i think
that's more of a solved problem
the harder problem is actually typesave
backends which is something that we're
not so clear about i think probably the
winner in this space especially for the
js ecosystem is graphql graphql itself
has a schema definition language instead
of a type language but it's pretty much
the same thing this is part of the spec
of graphql and you can see how they're
used on the graphql.org site you can
declare enums you can declare types
types can have ids or strings or numbers
or they can also embed other types and
as for queries you can also have a type
of query or you can have a type of
mutation and that is all wrapped up in
your overall schema
that's essentially the raw spec and
there's extensions that we can do to
that spec but based on these type
declarations we can start to generate
tooling everyone who's used graphql
probably knows this but there's a tool
called graphical if you haven't come
across it definitely check it out
because this is probably one of the most
effective inspirational influential
tools that i've ever come across
it's like a repo for your query so it
actually runs against a real graphql
endpoint you can do queries see those
sample responses you can also check out
inline documentation
even if it's deprecated we can note that
it's deprecated and we can tell people
what else they should be using
every single graphql request is
validated before it runs so if you get a
badly formed request it won't even go
through there's a very standard error
resolution process that happens when a
bad request comes in so this is very
similar to how typescript works for the
front end but applies to the back end
additionally if you use graphql right
you can also get savings in data
transfer that makes your app
work faster and your bandwidth go down
there's a lot of pros and cons to this
design and it's hotly debated so i'm not
going to cover it all but i just want to
make sure that the point is made that
because you have type save back-ends
then very good tooling can be generated
based on your type safe back-ends and
because it's an industry standard we
share the cost of developing things like
graphical and that makes graphql a lot
easier to work with
so from back end to front end we then
need to hook it up and that's the tricky
part one of the cool projects that i
like to see in this space is called
graphql code generator it says what it
does it takes graphql and it generates
code in our case it generates typescript
code and that's exactly what we need to
take types from backend to frontend this
isn't the only strategy in the space you
can also go from typescript to graphql
and that's what these two popular
projects do type graphql and graphql
nexus they both have different ways one
uses decorators the other uses standard
typescript functions but both are ways
of describing what your types are in a
way that can also be parsed to generate
graphql there's also smaller solutions
like type gql and deck api that are
exploring different solutions in this
problem space
however i just want to step back a
little bit
and address the elephant in the room
which is that we want to
enable all of this in order to get
better user experience by creating more
reliable apps without tech debt
but in order to get there we need to
stitch together all of these tools and
our developer experience goes down
especially at the initial part when
there's a learning curve and we have to
figure out how to make all these tools
talk together because they weren't
designed with a single coherent mindset
there's a lot of complexity in order to
get all your ducks in a row to get a
full stack type safe experience you need
to pick your backend resources and then
you need to write graphql resolvers for
them you need to generate typescript
types and then you also need to have
client graphql or typescript libraries
and then for everything else that you
might need like offline syncing or
real-time websockets you have to write
custom custom code and probably your the
open source ecosystem is not well
developed enough for you to do all of
this out of the box
so the end result of reaching this type
safe full stack react goal is that we
either glue together our own framework
and have to
maintain a lot of glue code or we use an
integrated framework designed for this
workflow and that's something i'm
interested in exploring at aws and
working on
so for each of these solutions we have
aws absync that provides our backend
resources like database but it also acts
as a graphql gateway graphql transform
which is an open source library that
helps to write these graphql resolvers
and typescript types and aws amplifier
helps to do the code generation but it
also provides the client libraries that
you can use to access the resources that
you've provided so let me show you what
this looks like and the ultimate vision
of
how we can reduce all the boilerplate
but actually still achieve this user
experience of full stack type safe react
so at aws we've actually extended
graphql graphql is made to be extensible
and one of those ways in which
it does that is this cool idea called
directives directives are anything with
an at on top of them so for example if
you write a type in standard schema
definition language and you have this
all these fields with standard graphql
sdl we can actually just add an add
model and that's some that only means
whatever we make it to mean graphql has
no opinion on that
so we can just throw it onto here and if
we have an integrator toolkit we can
actually spin up the resources that are
required
to make this into a crud enabled model
so we can say all right we have a type
post inside of our graphql let's spin up
the functionality to create posts read
post update and delete posts and do that
on the back end as well as the front end
and that's a fair amount of value add
typically the hard part of implementing
graphql back-ends is that you have to
write a lot of boilerplate for spinning
out all these things these are all
generated for you just by writing at
model
just six characters and it saves you a
lot of code now i want to stress that
this isn't the only solution that does
this
so hasura and fauna db both offer
similar approaches where you can just
specify the graphql schema and it spins
up the required database resources they
just have different underlying databases
backing them so for sure this is not at
all a unique insight but this is appsync
and this is the aws solution if you want
to use aws infrastructure
so all right we have add model what
other directives can we try we can also
try adding off right because you know
you want to have some authentication
when you do crud the only trick is you
do need some off service so of course if
you have an integrated tool chain then
you can add in something like amazon
cognito which is aws's standard off
service in front of appsync the main
trick that you have to figure out when
implementing such a solution is you have
to figure out how to let users specify
rules for who can access what so for
example you need ways to specify if the
whole model is private or if anyone can
read but only the owner of the model can
write and you need to be able to do this
at the model level as well as the field
level how about search imagine adding
search capability with one more
directive and then auto generating
search posts functionality with the
exact same workflow as everything else
that you use
so these are all really interesting and
there are other directives you can check
out with the graphql transform library
we're not going to cover everything
exactly but i just want to introduce you
to this concept because you've done the
sdl definition work whenever you use
graphql but you might as well use that
to spin up a back end and then you can
flow the types to the front end with an
auto generated toolchain
so for the amount of work that you do
just to do that it's actually very
powerful to express your full stack type
save react that actually brings us to
the demo that i've set up and i have
just enough time to do it so let's get
started i have here a simple create
react app it's been set up with
typescript and chakra ui for some nice
styling it's pretty much an extension of
what i already showed you with reactant
typescript here it's running and i
already have all the client side logic
in place and i can submit and it's going
to load
uh some values
the only issue is that there's no
persistence so if i refresh this app
it's not going to remember anything so
our task is to wire it up so it becomes
full stack and type safe the first thing
i'm going to do is i'm going to
initialize my back back-end so i'm going
to run amplify init and that actually
asks me a few questions to get these
process started i'm just going to enter
the defaults for all of them but
obviously you can customize it however
you like and it's going to auto detect
my create reactive settings so i don't
have to modify any of these but i could
if i wanted to all right the next
process is to add our backend graphql
api so i'm going to run amplify add api
which is the standard workflow amplify
add whatever category i'm trying to add
i'm going to pick graphql and again i'm
going to use choose the defaults for
whatever they offer me
by default they're going to offer me a
to-do model i should probably replace
that with something that i'm expecting
so it's just going to slightly extend
that into a simple blog post model and
now i can run amplify push to provision
those resources that i just established
as part of the push process we also get
to configure the code generation for
front-end types so we get a full stack
all the way from graphql all the way to
our front end types so let's say yes to
generate code and we're going to pick
typescript because
and we can just hit
enter to select all the defaults for the
rest so the push and code generation
does a couple things and i'm going to
talk you through them
the first thing that you should check
out is inside of your source folder you
have an aws exports.js file and this
contains all the configuration
information that is automatically set up
for you by the cli so all you really
need to do is import it just importing
it at the root of your app sets up your
app to connect with the aws backend
resources
the other thing that's changed is that
we have a new graphql folder where all
the typescript types have been generated
by default based on our models so for
queries we have get blog and list logs
and the mutation with create and update
and delete
so everything as you might expect
so inside of our app we can actually
import whatever queries have been auto
generated by our cli and then we can use
them inside of our reactant typescript
code
as you can see here i make use of
api.graphql and i need to import that
from the client library which i also
need to install so yarn add aws amplify
that gives us the api.graphql function
as well as its typings and we can also
use this to
do a create operation so you can import
create blog and set the variables to the
new values that we've set in our react
app we should also make sure to import
the create blog function from mutations
all right let's have a look at what
happens when we run this app now i'm
gonna let it take up the full screen
and
let's just autofill some content
autofill some more
and now when i refresh
all the data should continue to be there
something else that i really appreciate
about this workflow is that it
decomposes nicely to the underlying aws
services for more control if i need them
so i can type amplify console
here and it's going to open up the raw
services for example here we added the
graphql api so i can actually view this
in appsync and perform the exact same
graphql queries that i was doing in my
code
uh inside of this little ui that we have
over here so i can say list blogs
and i can just say give me all of them
body title image let's go
and this is exactly the query that i was
performing
and you can actually play with this but
also
you can see inside of our data sources i
can see that it's been provisioned by
dynamodb i can use other data sources
like
aurora and inside of dynamodb i have
access to all the other capabilities
that regular dynodb has as well as the
cost and scaling benefits so here i can
access all the raw data and access
without amplify and i have full ability
to eject from whatever setup has been
created so that's a really nice fallback
option if i need it now i realize that
was a really quick demo and it has no
time to cover all the really cool stuff
like real-time subscriptions or offline
caching but you can check that out on
your own
mostly i just want to introduce you to
the overall concept of an integrated
toolkit right amplify provides the cli
that you saw the client libraries that
you saw and the things that we didn't
see are ui components for you to get set
up quickly so for example authentication
you might want to have an authentication
component in your favorite framework so
using this unified workflow we can
access all the other categories that are
exposed to us via
aws like analytics aiml predictions
uh authentication data storage for with
amazon s3 and uh amplified data store
all of these are really really cool
features and it just take 10 hours to go
through all of them but i encourage you
to check it out if you're interested in
this idea of a full stack integrated
serverless approach that is typesafe
amplify only started about two years ago
and it's getting a lot of traction it's
one of the fastest scoring services
within aws and new categories are
getting added all the time
so in fact this year we actually added
live streaming video just in time for
the madness of 2020. it's almost like we
planned it but we did not anyway i want
to bring it back to type safe full stack
react and i want to acknowledge another
react-a-thon speaker lauren tan who
actually gave me this idea that she
first wrote about the strongly typed
graph and she says that the strongly
type graph builds upon end-to-end type
coverage and connects diverse domains
into a single graph and that's a little
bit of what we saw today just get to
give you a sample it gives teams near
real-time visibility of how changes in a
larger graph affect your entire
organization and that's the ultimate
vision of how we can shift left our
error discovery and resolution and
improve our developer velocity and
increase user experience without the
cost of developer experience so thank
you that was a really quick woven tour
throughout all of reactant typescript
and graphql all in aws and i hope you
stuck through it with me i'll be around
to answer any questions see ya and have
a great day tomorrow
wow
we did it
the first day of react-a-thon worldwide
thank you so much swix for that last uh
talk to finish out our wonderful first
day here
and thank you to all of our speakers um
and our workshop leaders and our topic
tables hosts and our sponsors and most
of all thank you all for being here
with us today
uh whether through hop in or through the
live stream um we're just so glad you
all could join us today and we hope you
had a ton of fun
so that is a wrap for our talks for the
day however there is still a lot more
happening jonathan you want to tell us a
little bit about what's going on
yeah so for the next hour and a half you
can check out the sponsor expo talk to
the engineers there
at the sponsor companies and they're
there for the next hour and a half
uh you can also continue to
network with people in the networking
session or the sessions section session
of the app uh and anjana is going to
give us a good reminder uh here as well
yeah so the um
the the
sponsor boost the networking sessions
the um the chat on the app all of these
great places to connect with people um
and as always we want to make sure that
everyone is adhering to the code of
conduct um again that is there to
protect us all and to make this a really
safe space for all of us
and so as always please keep that in
mind don't forget it's available at
reactathon.com
conduct and you can report any
violations
should the event arise
by clicking on somebody's profile and
then clicking report user to send a
message to the conference organizers so
let's all make sure that we are staying
respectful and safe and protecting each
other's experience as we continue to
engage with each other
and we're excited about tomorrow we're
going to have more great content both
tomorrow and wednesday but tomorrow
morning uh starting at 7 a.m pacific
time
we will have our workshops kicking off
at that time and sponsor expos start at
8 30
and then of course sponsor talks start
at 9 30 a.m pacific
and then back on the main stage here you
will see us
myself and angela
around 9 55
pacific time
absolutely so really excited to see
everybody back here again tomorrow and
in the meantime you can stick around for
the next few minutes uh before you jump
off to the sponsor booths and to chat
with everybody that you got to connect
with today you can also stick around to
to catch some nostalgic shots from
san francisco where we're hoping fingers
crossed with a little luck and a lot of
vaccines we might be able to see you all
uh back in person next year but uh for
now that's uh myself anjana vacheel and
my wonderful co-mc jonathan signing off
for this day one of react-a-thon we'll
see y'all tomorrow
bye
so
my
foreign
so